[Music]
hear you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hear ye
hear ye
hear you
y'all know what the day is
for the lord the day of the lords
what's going on
run a little late
uh busy day busy day good to see y'all
up in here
early
early on a sunday sunday salute always
so many y'all i mean rocket salute
rocket corey gerald maxillo
christopher hart what's going on j-hope
what's up
you already know
johnny dirt hands yeah yeah
you like that your life okay
hey byron
that's your name i'm just reading your
name
lydia bastard what's going on
necromancer what's up andy b drummond
what's up let me know how the levels is
going on mr ordinary vx you already know
salute zach riley what's going on
commander rodimus let's go
don will talk with two dollar super chat
charge you more to create ever more
sucker yeah you ever wanted his back get
his bag
oh atomic sand salute affordable i see
you on twitch what's going on thomas a
lot of what's up mr order again what's
up what's up what's up hustling motivate
my guy what's going on bro what's going
on oh everything as well william blank
blankenship
you know what i mean gandalf gandalf you
know
pac-man 209 salute the board game what's
up you already know levels are good okay
cool i need to be good
video acting weird i ain't got time to
try to fix it right now we got a show to
do the king i spoke to him earlier we
see what's up um yeah we got we got the
crew coming back from surprises um no
soft today sends off love legitimately
he has surgery he's going through it you
know what i'm saying johnny durham back
in the gym helped his wealth let's go
let's go that's what i'm talking about
inflation stay oh charlotte y'all
already waiting for king i already see
what y'all want
dover 360. you know
little doubt so look
is that black conflict x
yeah power to the people ring what's up
lord betray what's up
no doubt no doubt anyway so look we're
gonna get the king up in here everybody
up in here yeah praise the lord's like
jacks that's what i pray i gotta say
prayers a little some love hey
shout out to pop now
he doesn't say he'll be good he just
thinks he's low you know but yo anyway
things don't come too late i gotta find
attic i don't know what's going on with
him and um yeah oh jonathan b the og
what's up
hans castillo what's up damian percival
what's up audibles waiting okay
everybody's way to go i'm waiting on
king i don't know what he's gonna do
texas yeah yeah i didn't see you two
texas i don't know hold on is that the
legendary lock mort from last stand
media the man who remixes the best cuts
the best video idiots and it's ever my
guy
it's gonna be special bars bignate one
two one two
that's the most you get in today's zone
shanee what's up brother caught your
invite i wish i was up
later i'll be earlier to play with you
because we did a long raid and we got to
finish that joint but yeah halo infinite
we'll get that in with you you know what
i'm saying
you need to get on that destiny shitty
stop playing that's what you need to do
you know what i'm saying but we got a
lot of things going on today stormhorn
what's up y'all y'all up in here anyway
let me go find attic let's get him out
the bushes i don't know where yet and um
i'm gonna go i know king i'll be pulling
up in a minute we might be like
five minutes late
i gotta eat some food i'm hungry
see ya
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is
[Applause]
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until the time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with the gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled put on the be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
fire this is yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you're just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social
[Music]
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to starter regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but
[Applause]
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell an uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's
who let's do that again
and we are
live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line y'all this is
that standard this is what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on debt number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta-adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to advanced gg.com use code iron lord on
the checkout this is something i use all
the time got to support advanced gg
great products if you want to get your
workout on even if you don't work out
you're just gaming you need that focus
and again the hydration line for those
who don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lord
cognito here iron law podcast peace
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like sovereign you're
gonna get tossed in the bushes by king
david royalty and not a pretender
detrimental to an elemental what's the
avatar to a knee bender i gotta be meto
i know it's my destiny work to kinda
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right we're going to do some bike
checks right quick just to make sure do
your levels kick down your levels yeah
people want to hear you make sure you're
good are you ready
oh you ready
brothers
that's crap brothers
are you ready
for the next situation
on this episode of dragon ball king we
got we got the xbox kings right
alongside the playstation blues we got
the nintendo switches
right around here
can you dig it
i'll miss that movie i miss that movie
that is a classic no doubt we're doing
the warriors so look you already know
what it is here you hear ye and we are
live welcome to the two man i love
podcast just like you always wanted i'm
just chucking
[Laughter]
he said hold on hold on
respectfully respectfully
welcome to the islands podcast llc four
members and the lords of gaming.net
episode number 270. this is another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day and to date
we've got the ps5 price increase in
major markets
game pass friends and family plan hello
gamescom opening night live and phil
spencer's bloomberg interview to discuss
so we're gonna get right into it
i gotta give you gonna get the
background yeah yeah yeah you're gonna
be the context
fair enough so let's introduce the well
we don't got the four we got the three
first of all this time legitimately he's
legit legitimately send your love and
thoughts and pray well i guess he prays
because he could well to my mind send
the prayers all like
there you go he did everything though
shout out to softband just went through
you know i'm saying a little surgery or
whatever but he we saw him you know what
i mean yeah we saw him we saw him he's
okay you know what i mean but definitely
we told our brother to rest up it's
better for him to heal up definitely he
looked like a car wreck yeah he was
definitely trying to still pull up and
we had to tell him stop and take i can't
i could i could still hang guys yeah no
you're not hanging out
don't lie i thought so i've had a
microphone installed into us
he's talking to him and we talking to
his nose he's like yeah guys i can still
make it yeah no bro like stay home and
take your medicine please take your
medicine still functional
what a bet anyway
you do send him a message man like i
said our brother will be back but we
still got the three horsemen of gaming
my co-host with the colbos my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf my man lord attic
fresh on the car phone how we doing sir
doing pretty good uh yeah i'm on my way
home now
so i parked in and i was like man they
only got two people i was like i i i
could do it through my phone no we
didn't want to do things in the llc was
about to get us off out of there we were
fine
[Laughter]
just trying to take the problem
grab his leg it was funny when we were
trying to be the minute we were trying
to be shy to jump
right it's like nah that's not happening
does that happen but yo when you get it
please we we missed all bro i need the
dip super chats cause they coming in
already but other than that other than
uh destiny ringing uh with me what you
been up to
um
i've been watching a lot of tv here
lately i didn't really game
too much this week i did play i did play
a lot of fall guys and fortnite like an
absurd amount of fortnite i think
i've been adopting him
yeah and
you you can you gotta make him i i've
been putting work on fortnite yes i'm
not lying putting in that word
definitely when i get to my segment i'll
definitely expound on that sir no doubt
no
and of course we have the incredible
hulk of this aka the access gamer
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement who beloved
lord king how we doing sir also the
general of the stop snitching campaign
yo i'm doing fantastic all right so you
dudes yesterday wanted me to do that ksi
joint hell to the no
um
i i don't know man i'm an internet man
numbers you want to grow in there
listen i hear i hear what you're saying
but i don't want to make a mockery of my
stuff you know and if if jake paul was
fighting haseem rachman jr
who's a real boxer and the boxing uh
bodies were going to actually sanction
it then i was going all in on it ksi you
know having two fights in one night
i'm sorry dudes i mean if i can do a
joke stream about it yeah i'd do a joke
stream i'm not gonna milk your time when
the zone puts up real boxing events and
i'm i don't cover them when they fake
you know understand like when i
understand is a predetermined outcome
that was a predetermined outcome what
was gonna happen we all knew it we all
saw it the tube joint i i like fousey
right and i wanted to see fousey get
beat up so bad and and then um salt
poppy saw poppy winning i'm not saying i
didn't watch i watched i wasn't wasting
your time with it plus i had my son this
weekend so um he got he got a chance to
have
the most illustrious weekend a child's
life
the week that a child should have he he
had the most illustrious week he got a
new pair of crocs oh god shout out shout
out and he picked up he picked up the
lime green drawers oh my god
green cocktails
oh
god so what i've been playing this week
i ain't been playing destiny raids i
know you've been slicking aside i saw
you no no no no i'm coming i'm coming
back home relax i saw y'all y'all got to
take me through the last raid that i
didn't do um anyway vowel disciple
fortnight
oh what's up dudes i know
for a long time i i capped against
fortnite yeah
a long time been to me a long time
once they stopped that no build stuff
that's a long time bending me
i got a chance to play with
friends and family this whole week got a
chance to play with slow-mo backslash
salute i saw you put it up yeah yeah
yeah introduced me to um one of his uh
his friends so that was dope um his name
was king too and was was even bugged out
his name is david stop bugged out
right so then we see we have this
strategy that we do we fall in and we we
attack vader okay we kill vader and get
these legendary items and then we take
those items and go start killing
wholesale throughout the map like
wherever we kill vader at we rush from
that point so i played with um
lemon oh shout out to women clowns shot
the clown uh sinister and his rampaging
rogue behind i am so sick and tired of
people not staying in the team oh he
never do that in every game he always
that's the question that's uh that's a
m.o sinister he will go he leads us at a
deficit yeah all the time playing squads
and then you know we get killed so attic
is there and yo i'm gonna tell you when
dudes actually play correctly sinister
and then he he don't be having his mic
on this time of day oh damn you got to
get your stuff together anyway
so we're we're going to squats and we're
calling out numbers always playing with
young chris too
we're calling our numbers oh and they
know how to call like southwest on the
123rd
they got the official official call outs
yo it is so systematic how we break them
down throughout the map going through
the map killing people i think one match
we killed 50 people yeah
going through um and we did some epic
stuff uh it is it's real it's really
really absolutely 100 fun we get a lot
of uh victory royals i got to get on pub
g some dudes was asking me and then
somebody hit me up today was like halo
question mark i'm like yeah did they
drop something new
halo inside my dm don't do that but um
yeah it's it's been a real fun week i
saw the destiny stuff
also what was it it was something else
that launched in game pass
um oh what you call i've been playing
the little little beat-em-up joy you try
that one yeah yeah i tried to beat him
up
um
it was something that i downloaded but i
was having so much fun in fortnite with
these squads with everybody else oh me
and attic synced up our dance at the
same time lemon put it up to date so if
anybody goes to a 108
dragons tv you look at his timeline on
twitter and me and attic is in the
background and we synced our dance
perfectly so we're in the house
screaming my wife looked downstairs
she's like you okay and i'm like yeah
get it ah get it and it was just all for
dancing so
wow no doubt for the budget let me get
the super chat songs down here we're
waiting for adam to get to the crib so
um and i'm just gonna repeat anybody i
saw already but just wanna make sure
they get the credit shout out to donald
taco 2 super chat charge you more the
great ever born sagas salute i know what
the reference is there shout out to
hector the macho man 5 super chat or
hail the lords i've got my cup of looks
like a horse tears and waiting for the
king's messiness remember if your ps5
isn't turning on put your credit card in
for yo stop it render
finally super chat xbox gave us lies of
p why sony just gave us lines of msrp
wow and there we go
tears drink up dirty stop the messy this
donna taco let's see the chat the
warriors game was so good we need a new
one by rockstar at least a rock star
needs to make another non-gta game like
that yes can you dig it that was my
joint spontaneous 17 two pounds super
chat so the sony brigade loves
domination just like jim
texas father super chat it's the lord's
day got my lord's gear and i'm ready for
the shenanigans shout out to the song in
fl
inflation station hashtag stop snitching
hashtag xbox is the best box oh how'd it
go
okay let me play with your joystick
five dollar super chat i'm sending my
love to sob heart emoji if you could
give him give me his address i'll send
him my underwear to no
[Laughter]
no
no
i think let me play the joystick as
woman
[Laughter]
i'm on i'm on official record yeah
you're saying that right here
yeah no doubt hungry shitty finalism
hope for a fast recovery the profits off
no doubt the software drivers get well
soon thank you brother salute to you
eagle fan 765 welcome to the iron laws
podcast brought to you by everborns
charge them more wow
king ps kings playstation just give
willing to your supply of topics oh
playstation keeps get get willing to
yourself okay that's what he means i
think they're giving you bars for your
topic okay chris jones 2000 check [ __ ]
ducking mj on that demio stop it first
of all mr chris jones former scribe of
the buffalo gaming not in this salute
don't think i don't be knowing what
you'd be doing when you be dying in the
dungeon in your little hustle so we
gonna put that out there because
yo your skills is tied to hide something
are you talking about him rejoining
yeah yeah
shout out to the lords get well solved
no doubt thank you slow mo back slap
follow some chat king
kills people in fortnight and cusses
them out for 30 extra seconds had a lot
of fun getting done
is that your kid what's that about yes
sir yo you know how it is
we smoke like that's right we got you
hey you know what it is can't see the
stuff the stuff okay okay no doubt
country man follow super chat want a
cheaper price we have a console for you
it's called the ps4 yes we're still
making these
good good day lords hope you all had a
great weekend instead of love to solve
can't wait to hear your thoughts on
destiny 2. after years off i think i am
back no doubt everybody get hyped for
life for all that good stuff all that
good stuff salute to paris in the chat a
lot of people in the chat right now so
look we go get into my intro you know
i'm that guy lord cognito spread that
rhythm
i'm trying to try to speed it up
no no why why why we got real light skin
on that one
i gotta do the song you know
spreading that really little feeling
we had a good one we had the lone vault
wanderer really cool content creator
talking about gamescom talking about all
the stuff that's going on in the
industry also if you're on that patreon
you can catch that defining duke
ultimate we're talking about the effects
of embracer group check that out shout
out to cedric h file on super chat the
price of the brick just went up the wire
violence facility
yeah everybody's here for the comedy
i'll see you all right so we got that um
also shout out to the last word he
bought this ty got travis my man's big
daddy teams was on we talked about light
for everybody's hype season of the
plunder they got they see these vibes
right now it's pretty fun as far as me
we've been doing the king's fall raid
attic shout out to him shout out to
sinister shout out to forte shout out to
taz shout out to everybody we we really
are close we're close we just had to
break it up because our attic had to
leave yo what did they do different like
um because we all did kings fall rape we
really rocked that raid right so what
did they do different that is either
giving y'all some difficulty as well
because we have more powerful weapons
yeah it's contest mode you know once
contest mode is off yeah
because basically it's that power level
restriction you could go no higher than
a certain level and then the the enemies
ramp up higher each encounter okay so
you know without it the world's first is
done shout out to elysium that did that
i got front man look i've been i've
slammed it look fall to glass is my
favorite rape
i've slanded king's fall not because
it's not a great rate it's it's a rage
rate it's probably the most complete
rate you know i mean but the thing i
always hated about it was what it's one
of those raids if one person doesn't do
their job the whole thing falls apart
and then you start end up getting mad at
your man and you don't want to get mad
at your man you thought what i loved
about it yeah then you start asking you
know the question be like yo fan what
you running what's your love
yo when you click on the dude
why why why are you using the xeno why
are you using the the the yeah yeah it
did the argument whatever whatever so
you got that let's be real king first
[ __ ] you
addict then it goes see we ran it that
your way three times and we look how we
ain't getting no father now you gotta
run it my way
so the strat started it is a certain
level of hilarity when the when the
frustration kicking
so that's the beauty of ray sometimes so
shout out to everybody we will get it
done i know um taz or addict taz said he
want to do it after the um the what you
call it so
i don't know if you're around after the
part he said he won't try that but yeah
i've been doing that
all right cool so i've been doing that
season of the plunder um yo midnight
express on game pass y'all really cool
title it reminds me like a little double
dragon a little renegade but like it's
like seafood energy on xbox to be honest
and i believe it's made by a developer
made by one person
really good really good i'm really
enjoying it it's a simple game but it's
complex in the fighting system skill
trees and all that stuff very violent
very visceral they got counters they got
throws check that out on game pass
that's a really cool joy and yeah what
you can bent the knee bent the knee to
fortnite man had to bend and you got on
yeah man that destiny content got me and
then i had to go i had to go cough and i
was going around with silver surf and
fly i will say fortnite the engine and
no build mode changes the game and
that's the dope as well and it still has
one of the best engines in gamers so
salute to them you already know i'm
going to get a couple of super chats
real quick as they come in because i am
not solved
inside of 10
salute to the lords you already know
i've got my popcorn
freddy for king to go off for sony let's
go
just to add to the fun even u.s had a
price increase as playstation is mostly
selling the horizon ps5 bundle for 50
more no doubt and then we got danny
passion official two dollar super chat
i've seen multiple ps5s at pawnshop
never seen the series x or his block
that's what he see
well i mean they do sell like as far as
resale value
seller wall is high and it's getting
higher by the day
no doubt no doubt shout out to that
higher literally by the day yes
literally shout out to the ever born
saga 20 super chat i'm just wondering
where the line is
reselling the same games at full price
under the guise of remakes director's
cuts
10 next generation tax
no cross buy with pc no day and date no
playstation plus day date now raising
console prices
interesting i know oh he got to cut out
the way king went uh oh something i'm
i'm nervous so we i see you everyone i
see what you're saying we will talk
about it and um okay
okay i was worried you know when you
disappeared things happened
talking to you chat [ __ ] love seeing you
on unlocked again great episode thank
you bro that was a lot of fun shout out
to ryan mccaffrey the legend john that's
like gary already everborn saga again
two dollar super chat hashtag charge
them more hashtag hope of sonic
everybody cut that we will get that man
salute everybody there so look we got to
get into oh we got some people pulling
up we got some people pulling up we got
the legendary jay fonzarelli what's
going on games talk live how you doing
brother
hey what's going on man good to be here
that's the radio voice that's the voice
of the people right there how we doing
oh man i'm doing great doing great
just you know um
trying to have some fun with a certain
game but uh yeah a lot of issues but oh
i think i know what yeah
saints row okay oh yeah i heard about
that
yeah i heard about that as well yeah if
i would have bought that i would have
refunded it immediately
not if it was on the playstation
platform they would have did you nothing
sorry seriously reported by clickbank
the wallace thing i'm i was calling them
trying to recover my account
and i said they said yeah you're having
an issue call back tomorrow like
literally in the text
in the text you know they say they text
you you you're supposed to text an
assistant
oh whatever days i get tomorrow you try
too many times or whatever crazy what
the hell is this no doubt shot the
mexican zoidberg member for 21 months if
people needed two jobs for the ps3 then
people would need eight jobs for the ps5
how many jobs would you need for the pa
six oh wait there won't be a ps
so your people man get your people
kicked
har gee
waiting for sony to announce the price
increase for games due to inflation
around the world next week wow
messi i see y'all ready but anyway let
me uh we got rid of that we got all that
stuff going and uh let's get into this
poll for last week man last week's iop
poll results are in the people spoken
with the recent acquisition of major
game developers and publishers in the
last five years which do you perceive as
the greatest threat to the overall
consolidation of the games industry and
the winner was ten cent by a landslide
60
not even close so shout out to that
second place at 17 of the vote was uh
microsoft third place was embracing
group and last place coming at only 7 i
don't care nintendo is still number one
and outside group is tencent the
strongest threat out here y'all which i
think
uh let farms take that funds what you
think
is tencent the strongest i don't know
embracers looking pretty strong
they've been making a lot of moves and
uh
am i correct in saying that they might
have the most studios i mean own the
most studios because it seems like 10
cent has their hand in the cookie jar in
everybody's cookie jar right they own
steak and a lot of different hundreds of
different companies but embracer owns a
lot of studios
yeah i mean you know recently they
bought a few more studios but they
bought the square enix western division
i don't know embracer is looking like a
big uh
it looks like a big problem for sure
yeah now they're up there they're up
there for sure you know it's not i think
i think embracer is more of an issue
than tenzin
really interesting okay i think
they're trying to make money by buying
stock in certain of these companies
they they have influence but the last
decision for a lot of the companies
they're investing into isn't theirs
like and bracer has the final decision
look they're they're on the rise there's
no doubt as far as the acquisitions and
obviously now lord of the rings
franchise all that stuff
it's really really something to watch
there's no doubt and coming through it's
been a minute oh my man playstation in
the building salute mr bad bit how are
we doing sir
guys i'm so happy to be here because i
just i need a couple of good rants it's
been a week
i was gonna put a picture up the other
day remember when we were in boston um
uh you and i and i was like and it just
slipped my mind i went to go do
something else and i forgot and then uh
[ __ ] told me i think it was last night
he was like yo bad boy was going to be
on i'd say he must have read my mind
how you been brother it's been a minute
and uh busy that's what it's been very
busy but i'm i'm so happy to be here
y'all there's a lot of a lot of good
stuff to to talk about a lot
a lot of controversy in playstation land
that i can't wait to jump right into it
twitter was very interesting
hopefully it's not a lot of defense
forces
that's why i purposely wanted to speak
to you too because
both of your twitters were very
interesting and i can't wait to hear the
thought process of both of you on these
topics no doubt you already don't try to
sneak in as much of super chats before
we go and then we got shout out to the
um hold on we got alvin okay we got him
he's got uh final super chat some
thought third party and game pass would
fall off when first party hit but phil
giving us atomic heart roll long lives
of p and more trade rolls on all right
absolute salute that we love those games
look amazing that's what happens when
you actually take the money instead of
blocking somebody you just put content
on your your platform here we go
called me five hours super chat you know
why we here let kid get his messy boss
right now he's ready
then we got doge unleashed welcome lord
bronze welcome brother put the the crest
of the chat for him shout out to the max
otaku you already know ladies and
gentlemen super chat after years of
being haunted by oryx i've finally been
lifted from the curse of kings for raid
i'm finally at peace it can move forward
yes sir salute to you on the clear and
chaos actual two dollar super chat sony
straight up debo out here uh-oh
oh oh all right so look we're gonna get
into it y'all know as and saw what
eloquently saying
why we are here you know we gotta talk
about it uh playstation five
price increase and uh we got the blog
straight from the legend himself jim
ryan playstation 5 price to increase in
select markets due to global economic
environment including high inflation
rates so basically it is going to be the
new retail price coming to select
markets europe middle east and asia
aipac asia pacific latin america regions
plus canada and jim ryan says the global
economic environment is a challenge that
many of you around the world are no
doubt experiencing we're seeing high
global inflation rates as well as
adverse currency trends impacting
consumers and creating pressure on many
industries based on these challenging
economic conditions sie has made this
difficult decision to increase the
recommended retail price of playstation
5 in these select markets there will be
no price increase in the united states
and then they're going to break the um
the breakdown of what it would mean as
far as euros from 549 it would be now
it's up to 549 from 4.99 in uk pound it
was 449 to now 479
and then we got um japan effective
september 15th it's the yen you know
moves up to about 60 000 yen and then
china the one moves up to about four
thousand twenty ninety nine australia i
don't know what their currency is to say
aud to seven daddy died mexico fourteen
thousand nine nine nine and then
canadian 649 and then uh jim ryan also
goes on to say while this price increase
is a necessity given the current global
economic environment its impact on sti's
business our top priority continues to
be improving the playstation 5 supply
situation so as many players as possible
can experience everything that
playstation 5 offers and what's still to
come so before we get into it the people
have told me to shut up
they want to hear king they don't want
anything i'm talking about so kig if you
would like to tell the people how you
think about this situation so let me set
the scene for everyone who's out there
in youtube who the hell is that
and uh
i'm going to allow you to hear
what goes on in the meetings at uh
sony's oh okay
yesterday's price
is not two days
damn fat joe is up
shout out to joey crack up at the sony
meetings
so
now that we got that off
i'm gonna give you the exact particulars
on how this transpired yes
wake up well
oh no
we've had a
wrecking record seal
we put out the weaker most unstable
console we've ever created mark mark
you're a genius you're a genius that ssc
speed stuff was crazy they fell for it
hook line and sneakers
we raised prices on the games they
didn't blink because our people are
loyal
bias
and what we'll do is put 10 cents to the
dollar
if you think about it it's really 10
cents to the dollar they are
we we
actually have them
in the palm of our hands
well jim
um should we actually give back to them
right now because we're in an economic
crisis and things are really bad
what are you crazy
raise the prices in all the zones
that's what they said that's how it went
they said wait a second
hold on
ten cents to the dollar put it up let's
go
take it
they will take it they will fight back
anybody that denies it is not a good
value this is a premium console
oh that's the vibe
they will pay for greatness remember
that oh we are the home of the bangers
what is the banger jim i have absolutely
no idea
where you come from we don't
what the kids say it's what the kids say
that's what the kids say
i mean the kids say bangers so we get
them
all right now so we're gonna have to
split this money up well how much we
gonna give back to the people not a damn
thing
right now it's inflation outside i can't
give back no money man
all this money it's mine
and it's delicious
delicious
so all you guys that want a playstation
[Laughter]
kid
fifty dollars more for you
what i just can't believe he got props
he looks and sounds exactly like a
saints row character i swear
what about the u.s hold on microsoft
creeping up there don't don't you raise
that
that's what i said why not all the
markets microsoft on eye tail over there
don't you dare raise that price in the
u.s can't have that over here but
everywhere else make them play
microsoft is behind everywhere else
make them pay
oh so the thought process is because
you're ahead in the other regions that
you okay but where it's competitive okay
no no no right now this is knockout
dragon fighting these streets right now
we're about to lose but we can't get
that up just like that no no no no the
perception is
it's strong over here
we gonna get that money across the world
next week you never know
might be in the u.s
raising prices hey
somebody get me uh
a little side dingy for the boat here
what is the side d
was it a side car to a boat what are we
doing i just love like king's first
impression is literally the anchor man
from the chappelle show then he's got
this like this like this ox wrangler
like southern draw that i just
it's amazing
oh yeah
without it we've uh heard from some sony
representatives i just okay so i did
that all that stuff right and um
my other topic
wasn't this
right
they actually keep giving me active
stuff
to fight with i think this is a travesty
the fact of the matter is
raising prices and this is unprecedented
this is the first time in the history of
video games i can see if something is
discounted and taken off the shelves and
that's that raises the the value of the
console right if once you found out that
they're not making a certain console and
there's a limited edition or whatever
the hell and they just stopped producing
it the market of it goes up it's
supposed to but an actively produced
console that's on the market now people
consumers are looking for a rebate a
price deduction
in some form or fashion that they can
get the console because you have some
people waiting well you know 500 is too
much i'll wait until it goes to 449 or
whatever or if they put a bundle in even
when they do put a bundle in they raise
the price of the bundle so it's not
really a bundle where is your you're
gaining something or they're putting it
in for free no they're including that
game in the price of the bundle right so
there's no winds there you're not
getting anything uh on the short of the
bundle
so the fact of the matter i actively
produce manufactured console in the
store today
if you went the day before you got it at
4 49 yeah i mean well for 4.99 and then
you go back the next day and the guy
says well you know it's 5 49 now you're
like what
um i just went home and y'all was close
so i said i come back in the morning to
pick it up well that'll be fifty dollars
more that's that's the
the retail price of it and you you're
like why what the what did they do did
they put something in a box did
something did they add something did
they put a camera or something no no no
no they just raised the price
yeah kind of unprecedented in the in the
console space it show uh kind of shook
up the the internet completely yeah we
got to talk about it man it's coming
back but let's get let's get uh mr bad
[ __ ] because i i am curious about you
um obviously representing the trophy
room you know what i'm saying what you
doing on playstation so like what's your
thought process about this whole
announcement and you know from jim ryan
and the team
obviously i woke up to this news and
they put it out at the right time while
like everybody's asleep um
because i woke up to this i was like
this is one of the most
tone-deaf messages
i've ever seen like even just with their
like immediate like due to the current
economic challenges blah blah blah you
know go global inflation rates you would
think that would maybe come into like
and we're not going to increase it
across the board right like
but instead they're just
i truly think
playstation's mindset is because
everything's going up in price
we won't be judged too difficulty or
difficultly
on this
and that's why it's just it's it's not
like
they honestly think that they can get
away with it right and that's the thing
that kind of bothers me to me it's it's
not like the microsoft v sony thing at
all i actually look at nintendo like
let's all take a look at nintendo
nintendo is a company to me when i see
it outside looking in
treats their consumers like dog crap
right like don't try to emulate things
we're not trying to sell
to you we're not even gonna try to
preserve our history you have six months
to buy mario we are going to charge you
for the worst online ever and even them
who do not have another you know place
to make money and it's just solely games
right even then they saw what's going on
right now and going we're not going to
charge you extra yeah
right what to me
if playstation 5 was still losing money
there's an argument to be had fine maybe
you need to
up it like maybe there's a valid
argument somewhere there but the fact
that
months after the playstation 5 came out
they're boasting about this console is
already profitable
and so what's really what's really
saying what they're trying to say to you
really is hey we're making
money on this console still but we want
to make as much money as we were making
before inflation hit
and that's just not a good excuse
and i've seen people go
the defense voice go but joe you know
the next iphone is going to be 100 bucks
more
rumor has it but guess what that's a new
iphone
it's not exactly there's at least some
improvements across the board and it's
not even like the fan base is happy
about it they're complaining too you
just look at a mac rumors uh forum and
they'll tell you they're not happy about
it either
right so it's like that's not a great
argument and then i see people go out
there like well because
we're such a premium i've got so many
great experiences i'm happy to pay more
it's like no
why are you why are we championing
he's containing i've never seen this
why are we why are we defending amoral
companies that don't care like literally
playstation just raised the price we
should be outraged we should be upset
this should not be the case
it's just it doesn't make any
sense why anyone would defend this move
because it's absolutely tone death
even even nintendo again the company
that's like we're going to take mario
the mario collection off at six months
ago
yeah even took a look and said no we're
not going to again like microsoft you
just bought activision for 70 billion i
don't expect you to raise the price you
you got word you got windows you can
make money somewhere else nintendo this
is their only bread and butter right
here decided not to
so to me it seems like sony is taking
cues
from the wrong chapters of the of the
nintendo playbook and saying well we're
playstation and we have got a war so
here you go
and that's that's what i think is so
i think that like
the underlying
tone here with playstation coming from
the fan base is like we the fan base of
playstation have gotten some of the best
games that that that we've gotten over
the past few years
but it doesn't feel like we're quote
unquote winning
it doesn't feel like they are treating
us as a community which is why i give so
much props to xbox because take a look
at their community management how they
reach out the brand alone yeah it makes
you forget it's a billion dollar plus
company it makes it feel grassroots and
it's just trillions
i'm talking about xbox i'm talking about
xbox game division no no no no no no
like it's called microsoft xbox oh my
god
moving
like they'll make you forget about it
yes and that's the
that's the thing that i think
we as the community as a in in the
playstation land yeah is right now just
not liking the tone because this is like
one sentence away from listen my cat
food it got up in price and we got to do
something about mr mittens
it honestly sucks there's no ex like
there's no real excuse for it it's not
like after you bought this console
that's it they have a whole ecosystem of
which digital is growing
exponentially year in year out you're
going to be buying things in their
marketplace
so it's not like they're really losing
any money it's just that they want to
keep profits of the weight
oh no fair enough for good points i
gotta give father thank you for the rain
i needed that no no i don't know we i'm
not finished with them all yeah we go if
we go bring this back on some other
stuff too but i gotta get my brother mr
j fonzarelli man you know i know you're
very passionate you know from every all
our discussions and in the past you're
probably one of the more pro consumer
gamers i've been around and you're
passionate you wear it on your sleeve
and i saw i saw your comments and it hit
home but i wanted to now that it's had a
little more time to settle right you
know what is your thought process on the
playstation 5 price increase
um first i'll say gamers i love you
could the community i love you
but as consumers you're dummies
you're dummies
i'm sorry that community is so full of
stupid ignorant people um
and and as consumers right mind you
because
here's what's happening bad [ __ ] said
that you know they think they can get
away with it they have they will
it's not going to hurt their sales
they're going to continue to sell these
playstation 5s at this premium cost
because the gamers will allow it
they allow the 70
game price hike they're just fine with
it you know
there's not a lot of people out there
not a lot of consumers that have
conviction on on things anymore
um whatever these companies try to
shovel you you're just going to eat it
up you're going to pay for it and that's
that's what i've learned over the past
few years um being in this community
um
it's it's this mentality that you know
hey i gotta have it it doesn't matter
the cost if i really love this product
i'm gonna pay for it it doesn't matter
um and then they'll use excuses like
well it's subjective you know my my
value isn't the same as yours and things
like that but there's always a baseline
to things people
that's what i try to preach to people is
there's a baseline to everything
and consoles this is so unprecedented
two years into a cycle you're going to
raise the price when typically two years
into a cycle you might see a decrease in
price that is true it's insane
like this is about the time people are
waiting and saying hey you know uh
little johnny we'll buy you a
playstation 5 when it's a little cheaper
in a couple of years
now it's like
to those people it's like well little
johnny you're gonna have to wait a
little bit longer
no they tell a little johnny you're
getting a serious ass we tired of this
waiting thing you ain't complaining one
more season about this you're getting a
series s but that's you know my my whole
thing is you know and i don't really
want to be so harsh on people but it's
it's true
i mean as consumers we'll go out there
and pay through the nose sometimes for
something if we feel the value in it and
again there's always a baseline to
everything and the baseline here is
being raised yet again on sony's side
and i know sony didn't start with the 70
games i know that started with
activision and you know a couple other
studios
but now
here again sony we're raising the price
on this it is one of the most tone-deaf
moves i've seen in a very very long time
and for anybody to defend this
i'm sorry it's wrong
it doesn't make any sense
if whether or not you buy it or pay for
it or say it's okay to be
whatever but to defend a big corporation
like this is just really weird as a
consumer
um any time there's price hikes involved
yeah i just want to follow up one quick
question on what you said fox because
you're making a point and i want to be
clear we're talking about a specific
subset of of the community obviously
everybody right just a specific subset
that you see specifically yeah like all
social media that is defending and going
on about that not everybody there's a
lot i'm talking about the majority of
the community oh i'm talking about your
joy the community
when when i'm saying people are dummies
about buying it yeah that is the
majority of the community a hundred
percent but from what i've seen online
uh you know
uh these guys um these sony guys online
on in our twitter space you know
we're just a small
group of people that's all i was going
to say i see
a few thousand tweets here and there you
know every every you know year whatever
but we are really a minority in this big
community community of gamers uh there's
millions of gamers out there but there's
millions of dummies
it's i mean look
the 70 game thing has already been done
and over with people have accepted it
all of us who had conviction and stopped
paying for it and didn't pay for any of
these games at 70 bucks
we lost
there's nothing there to gain
for me personally like you know and i'll
say it here on this show for the first
time out in public i've said it to
friends just recently
my stance on the 70 games
remains the same i think it's ridiculous
right i think it's ridiculous it's
overpriced
but
will i stay not buying 70 games
i don't think so that's the question
that's honest i think i think when i
think when big games come out that i
want to play because i do suffer from
fomo
i i'm going to have to buy into it
because everybody accepted it okay you
know what funds you and i really didn't
accept it and i haven't brought a 70
dollar game yet i'm keeping a hundred i
haven't yet you haven't either yet
and i know where your concern is because
you're probably looking at god of war
coming and you're probably saying
because you we already got a place
for the hike up in the price right so
you can say we are the beneficiaries of
of having uh cash at that moment for
those people that don't have the cash at
that moment and you were saving up the
money during the a pandemic
during a recession and you're saying
well i finally got some money saved to
the side and then they they raised the
bar on you again yeah yeah and they
raised the ball on the games this is
really weird but i just say to say this
right i know you see
those games on the horizon
that you'll pay that 70 dollars for and
you don't want to say you know i'm gonna
be a hypocrite now i'm not cause i'm not
gonna wait i'm not gonna wait and you
already conceded to that point but maybe
that won't happen right
maybe if we make such a noise such a
noise that some of these first-party
games can make it into this service that
they forced on us because they took one
part of
a failed uh part of the service and a
functional part melded it together good
but put content in there that's
compelling enough for me to give you my
money and show me the value and we
demand that part let's do that part
right and if we loud enough because i
haven't did it yet and i'm afraid that
it's going to happen just like you i'm
afraid that 70 cause god of war is going
to be in the store and i'm going to look
at that 70 and i'm going to say man
i'm not naive to the fact that hey this
is happening right industry-wide i think
that eventually xbox will even follow
suit and they'll have 70 games as well i
don't have
i thought that way back
two years what year and a half two years
ago when i talked to aaron greenberg on
rdx and i asked him a question about 70
games yes
his his answer spoke volumes to me um
i see them following suit
um that's not my problem i'm not naive
to this
it was all about principle at this point
right but at the end of the day it's
it's harming my gameplay it's harming my
gaming experiences because i know i
suffer from fomo and i know when the
game comes out like god of war it gets
spoiled on the internet quick
and it ruins games for me and that's not
fair
so so to myself it's not fair to myself
so to keep me from playing these
experiences however
um it just does not make sense to hold
back and and and continue to say i'm not
going to buy any game for 70 bucks
because
it's here to stay like if we would have
collectively not bought these games at
70 bucks right but they would have heard
of it
for sure
but
it's not happening and that's why i see
this as being the same thing with
playstation 5. this increase in price
it's the same thing people are going to
pay for it well it's it's certainly just
that simple
we have
915 people please
please hit the like button hit that like
share it out um getting around because
we don't get bad bit often and when we
get fonz in here and he's dropping
knowledge please
share this out to your friends no doubt
if i'm sorry
we cut you off yeah and people are
people are going to continue to buy the
playstation 5 at this new new price it's
not going to change anything like that
that's what this does do it does give
them a black guy show them that they're
tone deaf and they're doing a lot of
other things not just this price
increase this is a culmination of so
many different things that they're doing
they sony i will say this i think sony
are losing their way
they are losing their way
they are not the same sony they were
last gen
they are not
this is a different sony people if
you're thinking they're they're the same
you're sadly mistaken gym box i am
hoping
i am praying that they can continue to
bring their excellent bangers their
single-player bangers out let's relax on
that i really am because at this point
with all the changes they've been making
everything they've been doing
it's it's not a good look well that's
the thing sorry it's scary it's scary
that's the thing they're relying on
there it's nintendo logic we're relying
on our ip because they know fomo exists
right so they're just like we have god
of war you're gonna pay this extra 50
bucks it's same with like like splatoon
it's like
you know this online sucks you know you
need your phone to just have voice chat
but it's splatoon and you're going to
buy it right
now like
that that's it
yeah
if anything the the
the playstation thing's worth because
the switch is nintendo's always been
transparent we have bad internet you're
going to have to use the phone like
playstation came out there
they for for two years you're like yeah
you know what's going on and then one
day you get to the door you're about to
open go inside it's locked like what's
going on why is it you need fifty
dollars we need to get that locksmith
out here and fix this this law
yeah christopher hart i appreciate it i
appreciate you bro but why do you keep
comparing your playstation five to the
oculus stop it wait a second oh stupid
we're not gonna we're not gonna do that
and i told y'all before
i said out of the major three
sony is gonna be the one to do it
not two weeks later
two weeks later
they did exactly what i said and i told
you why they would do it because you
guys are gullible enough to sit there
and keep taking it and not being allowed
enough to say we will not take these
practices
but the practices in place is there to
make that company money not saying that
these companies don't make money and
they're not in the business of making
money
but
they're in the business of having good
relations with their consumers and
they're not doing the second part of the
money-making scheme i'm i'm not sure on
how much you're expanding on this topic
or whatever i am i got more than say i'm
talking yeah because when i'm talking
about
you know a culmination of things that
they've been doing and dropping the ball
i know where you're going because i got
bored for that dude there's so much
they've been doing that is so tone-deaf
they are not listening to any type of
gaming fan base out there at all
my number one gripe with them right now
is the fact that yes i brought up the
fact that i i'm hoping that they keep
these bangers coming because
they are now
like telling us
that games that we all want sequels to
aren't going to be made but let's make
tv and film adaptations about them right
blah blah blah ridiculous
how ridiculous uh is this
you know what we got
we got a patch for bloodborne liza p was
shown
and everybody is surrounding this game
because it looks like the successor to
bloodborne it looks like a bloodborne
sequel everybody is loving it because of
that sony over here they've been asking
for bloodborne too for so long i've
wanted bloodborne 2 for so long sony
don't give a damn but let's make some tv
or film about bloodborne i mean yeah
because dawn was it days gone was a game
that a lot of people want to see a
sequel to right i myself enjoyed the
game and thought you know it had its
issues but if it had a sophomore outing
a foundation really good they're going
to nail the second one we're not getting
that but guess what we're getting a
movie
why
they didn't like the game why are we
getting a movie on an ip
that they don't even like i hear you i
just want to i just wanted to mean i
just want to jump in for a second for
the sake of devil's advocate and i
everything i feel you like trust me
you're preaching preaching i wanted to
say like i get that right and and as the
hardcore gamer right we love what we
love and there's these classic sony ips
that are just phenomenal right and like
you said you look at a days going
situation and you look at okay this is a
great foundation for the future it may
not have been perfect right
but you could see the start of a new
franchise you know budding if they you
know put in enough with the sequel and
then you hear about obviously the movie
you hear about last of us remake remake
you know that kind of thing yeah and
you're like you see where where the
thing is and the question is
you know we talked about jim ryan made a
statement
he's been on record for saying multiple
times like
he is not satisfied with where the video
game industry is from the sony
standpoint from a financial revenue
standpoint he feels these games are
blockbusters masterpieces he feels they
should be way bigger like competing with
all the biggest media genres and do you
think it's just more of like do you
fought them
for saying
we want to grow financially outside of
just the space of game because this
gaming box is limited for as much as we
love these games right and king has
always said this you know when we talked
about the you know he goes with the
hashtag you're not enough but like
they're not happy when you know there's
only 10 million sold for yeah class of
us or horizon what like those numbers
haven't come out in typical
sony fashion so so the question becomes
for the overall revenue of the company
yeah when these other games and are they
looking at these other things that are
doing major and in other mediums that
they want to mimic that or is that
something to you that's still no no
they've lost their way here's here's the
thing
i'm not mad that they want to make more
money that's what a company should do
right i'm not mad at that and i'm not
mad that they're making film and tv and
movie adaptations of these games
but what i'm mad at is that they're
making films and tv adaptations or you
know of these games that they don't want
to make sequels to anymore it's like
they're leaving them aside
and they're losing their their their way
in that they're they're not being
playstation they're not being for the
gamer
who who are they for for the moviegoer
you know it that's not what your money
died
we're not we're look i i don't care
about all these gaming movies like i
haven't watched uncharted i don't
tv show tv halo show sucks
but the checks say otherwise the check
is coming in i don't i don't personally
watch this stuff and and i will go on
record as saying this i guarantee you
that there's a lot of people out there
that watch like the halo tv show that
don't ever don't know anything about him
probably don't even play the video game
hurts
but
but that's the i mean at the play
devil's advocate that's the audience
they want they want the guy that's not
familiar because you've got to please
your gamers
the game
period at the end of the day
sometimes
what no you're up uh you have a patient
i said sometimes
even though the company wants it isn't
the right direction for the company
microsoft wanted to go to an all media
outlet that focused everything at as a
center and not just gaming they got
ridiculed through the entire internet
because of it it's like look sony's
making money off these games the problem
is corporate grade they want more that
you know jim ryan wants to go into these
meetings and say i'm making triple what
your past people did he's the money guy
he doesn't want to go into these
meetings saying you know i'm making
we're making good money you know you
know we made 3 billion this year we we
we we made 2 billion last year i want to
see 4 billion this year and 2 billion
last year he wants to go in there with
the consistency of i doubled your money
every year right and
they are getting to that max cat
standpoint where
they either have to casualize their game
to a huge drastic audience which they
are doing you know what's funny is the
original last of us had had
difficulty trophies and the remake
doesn't
so
they are
doing things like that like removing
difficulty trophies for
games
just because they want to be more
appealing to everyone that plays their
games look i don't particularly care
about stuff like that but i know a lot
of people it's like yo like
it's one thing not to put the difficulty
trophies in a game such as like god of
war where you can beat the game on hard
and it gives you nothing in terms of
trophies
it's another thing to take one out of a
remake from that had the previous one in
it but the fact that them casualizing it
and raising the prices
that
that that doesn't make any sense right
if you're casualizing it
shouldn't you lower the price shouldn't
you really make it more appealing for
the people that aren't looking at your
console like
i'm not looking at the console to play
hardcore games right let's just say that
they took out the the
the hardcore part of the the game right
uh for you to get these trophies
but at the same time you raise the price
you raise the barrier of entry to your
ecosystem
i don't understand this for the
corporate agreement they want more money
that's all it is they want more money
it's unprecedented in the consoles
official
that's why they do the ten dollar ps5
tax that's why they charge you two which
is pretty much the same thing like we
should you should know what should be
surprised they're charging you to use
the features of the system they promoted
to you thank you like why would anyone
be surprised if they're going to charge
another 50 for the console itself and
you know what's funny the fact there's
one thing that people aren't bringing up
that is
crazy to me
they charged everyone around the world
but the only place that actually is
competing to them and if you wanted to i
myself would be infuriated if i was a
gamer anywhere else for the united
states right now because sony literally
went on a stage and said
all of y'all
you're gonna buy us stuff regardless
you know xbox might do okay over there
but we generally win those those
territories so we're gonna raise all
that by fifty dollars yeah
but then we're gonna go out on a podium
and say it's because of inflation but
they're not raising prices on one of the
most successful areas that they sell so
it makes no sense right there says it's
not inflation because if it was
inflation they would have raised it in
america where a lot of their cells
already are yeah and i think it's up to
microsoft real talk to the to the
broader point there it's up to microsoft
to pour the marketing dollars into
europe into the middle east you know
localization still a problem for them
they need to do that type of effort that
ground roots that they've done in in the
uk and the united states in those other
areas to capitalize on that mistake that
being said though when we talk about
like the movies and tv
the reason why they they want to do it
is because they have ip they own they
have a production studio that is
successful
and they're seeing the mcu and going why
can't we do this all franchises
our franchises that already have these
fan bases and expand them like real talk
i watched the last of this movie on
netflix with my friend amy right i'm i'm
a i'm an uncharted fan i enjoyed the
movie it was fine
my friend amy doesn't know
[Music]
the audible grunts that were made she's
now a fan she likes that movie she's
going to see another then you get that's
what they're going for they potentially
hold up what's like i'm gonna just throw
this in it and potentially
that hey let's use amy's example right
is a non-gamer that now has a
recognition to a franchise they knew
nothing about and now if a game comes
out a new uncharted re-bastard or
whatever
there may be a potential you know what i
remember tomorrow
and now i have something to do on that
already
and this is just one specific standpoint
i know
it probably won't happen again but the
fact that they greenlit
a t uh uh a day's gone tv show but won't
greenland another game so what what
that's what the audience is not
attributing to but there's not going to
be another game
there's a day's going game that exists
currently it didn't exist so it's it you
can still play but i'll just say your
point though
and playstation productions is a
different company
than playstation in a hole so to me it
makes notes like honest to god it makes
no sense for me
it makes no sense why day's gone or even
gravity rush but they're probably
thinking well gravity rush we got sony
animation and they've done really good
work so far they could build something
weird there it's kind of like shang chi
right that wasn't a popular uh you know
marble run right but damn does that
movie fantastic like
the mcu has been able to revive things
wait you said the the character himself
yeah wasn't a popular no he said it was
i'm not the i'm not the comic book
aficionado i am that movie but that's
the thing that movie made me interested
in the character right exactly and
that's what they're trying to do that's
the cross synergy right where it's like
like i i don't know how many people back
when i was a kid was just like yo you
know who my favorite superhero is
it's like you didn't have that but now
like black panther was big but now he's
huge right like shane is now a name like
a like a name that's broken into the
main street that's what they want from
that
but
again i have no idea why it was days
gone maybe it's something cool like hey
they they're bringing the talented
directors in or or your scriptwriters
going you just pick it doesn't matter
that's cool but i don't even know i have
a question like um from
from one of the people that we talked to
in the background and i know he's
watching right now so i'm going to read
it right now so you know that i read it
but
dmd the biggest question that the gaming
companies have to do with with gamers oh
wait there's a tv and film
can we create an uncharted movie to make
400 million and also get those people to
come back right now i don't think
that the marriage happened yet with film
and game correct right because
this is and and if anybody's listening
if you steal it i swear to god coming
for you
um this is how you do it right you have
let's say netflix and netflix let's say
netflix went out and brought sony
netflix goes on by sony you watch the
uncharted
uh
movie you have an icon pop up at the
bottom and says
at this point in the game this exact
scene in the game because when he was
doing that scene falling out of the the
plane it's in the game
yeah you can transition from this part
to the game right now and if you're
having a cloud technology hit that
button
you do the implementing
just jump into the game
that's when you marry it
and then you stop it at let's say one or
two minutes while you're playing the
game do you like this game would you
like to purchase this game oh yeah you
know the ads
come on yeah you did it right
and that's how you can actually
get that fan base over
to the console space and we're going to
get to that space that space is going to
happen i don't have any problem with any
company taking their ips and making
money someplace else please do so
do not raise a console's price that
you're manufacturing
currently at this moment
from one day to the next do not do that
you can lower the price you can help the
consumer but do not take the consumer
and take that consumer for granted
anybody that's in this chat championing
that type of practice i want you to
think of your favorite thing right now
your favorite thing let's say it's a bag
of chips that you go to the store and
you get for 50 cents every day you go to
the store you get your 50 cent chips and
you get your juice and you go to school
you know
your mother sent me to the store with
one dollar
you can't get your juice no more because
your chips now is a dollar
you're going to be outraged as a child
this is exactly what they are doing
they're not translating their revenue
stream that they're making from other
places because you brought up uncharted
they got that money
they didn't pay it back
they didn't give it back they don't care
to give it back what they care to do is
keep
ripping and tearing away from the fabric
and this is the reason why i said
there's not going to be a playstation 6
because with practices just like this
this is not consumer friendly and at
some point you will wake up and the day
that you do wake up is the day that they
are in trouble well that's the thing
they need to be humbled
there has not been a moment that they've
been humbled because we can like we can
complain you know
and moan about it
but the fact of the matter is saying
with the analytics thing
the encounters already counted yeah they
know what they can get away with again
they're taking the page out of nintendo
i think and there's a there's a
realization of this audience the the
twitter community you know to quote dave
chappelle it's not real it's not a real
place and we're getting more and more
companies that are starting to realize
that your twitter outrage that you're
mad about every day
isn't actually going to equate to
anything
so they're like we're coming to a point
where companies are deciding to talk to
us less because we yell at them so much
so like in in actuality until until
their numbers are affected right they're
going to keep doing what they're going
to do
until their numbers until people are
actually loud enough outside the small
medium right
then they're going to actually start
reverting back but the fact that this
happened on what thursday and it seemed
like it died on friday
it that's the thing it's just like okay
well this is business as normal and it's
it's it's a combination of like you have
like the toxic positive folks that have
an opportunity with their larger fan
bases to go hey we can make a positive
change but we're going to criticize you
just enough that we won't make you mad
so that you could give us a copy of the
last are you implying he's referring to
the toxic positivity
[Applause]
you know what the funny thing about it
that
is
like this happened
and it trended for maybe 12 13 hours on
twitter yeah uh phil spencer traded for
four days over an interview
that's a good point
you trained it for four days over an
interview
but playstation raising the price isn't
everywhere but america trended and not
even 24 hours and everyone's not talking
about it like there's going to be more
people that are out of that toxic
positivity thing that got to spin
everything into a nice little bow
gonna talk about this on podcasts gonna
be videos
you know the talks and positivity people
where's one video by then
where's one tweet bother and what's
funny is when they bring stuff up they
gotta they gotta spin it in the in in a
positive way well you know it's the
economy the way it ended up in the in
america explain that
you're talking about the what about it
let me know what your favorite things
i gotta get some balls
america is the only marketplace
seemingly
that is truly competitive with xbox and
playstation so playstation won't do it
here
but everywhere else where they have that
lead where they know they could get away
with it like again middle east europe
they're going to raise the price because
they know and i think at like you know
when you have not just xbox again i
expect them to your trillion dollar
company with a t but when you see people
like nintendo
right when you see people like nintendo
this is the only market that they're in
and going now and and they're the ones
that love to again we complain about the
last of us but like look at donkey kong
tropical freeze though
yeah and even them they're just like no
we're not gonna do it
that is just telling and if i was listen
if i was phil spencer and i walked out
of that interview i would be pouring a
lot more marketing dollars into places
that i normally wouldn't have
to gain that momentum
i think in the long run that 50
difference is going to make is going to
make a difference
real talk addict like you could call it
a black friday cell and just you could
even just the smallest decrease is going
to get people's eyes like if you drop
that series
nobody's talking about here about the
u.s market
yeah they didn't raise the price
but how long has it been since you've
seen a direct or anything where they've
sent they've sent consoles out by
themselves they're bundled they're
bundled for 550 bucks folks but guess
what a game of their own
they're not paying to put in there it's
theirs
they're they're they're giving me that
game you know you don't got to go but
they're doing that for two for two
reasons one to bolster the sales of
horizon forbidden west
and two to make it look like they're
doing something nice there but guess
what they're charging you 550 bucks for
a playstation 5 here in america
you know those bundles are coming in
pretty high listen like the attachment
rate what's going on
and the attachment rate was going to be
high for that thing and you're right it
is a way for them to to artificially
increase it by a good 50 bucks so you're
paying that anyway because you're you're
thinking well you know what
i was going to buy horizon anyway
you know those games aren't selling very
well right here you know
you know what this could be and we're
not really talking about it too much
uh this could just be a straight-up
thing where it's like playstation
looking at these scalloping prices and
they're like yo if people making that
money i might as well make that money
you know fifty dollars ain't that much
people charging 200 on that on ebay and
amazon and stuff so i'ma charge fifty
dollars more it's like look and the
funny thing is
how long does this last for a couple of
years forever like
shout out to the one
okay
[Applause]
because i know you have a point and i've
been nobody said this point yet mm-hmm
i just want to address the chat real
quick before call goes you know we got
over a thousand people in the chat if
you guys ain't subscribed man subscribe
man we we you know there's there's a
good like 4 30 40 percent of the people
that watch the show ain't subbed to us
yeah we appreciate it definitely hit
that like button too let's get that
let's get that high up man see what's
funny is the more you like the podcast
the higher our silly becomes so feed
into our spirit ball let's go hit that
like button i can't with you there ain't
no [ __ ]
fortnite right now so i got to make one
now
feed into our spirit bomb hit that like
button get that over 500 before the end
of the show i'll give them something
better
thank you more
[Music]
but look you know you guys saying a lot
of points and it got me thinking man
this this was shocking news to me like i
didn't see this one coming um
and i think i had a very good point i
actually took some of all i was thinking
about which was
the the optics
and the subliminals if you're a person
that lives in these other regions
because what quinn essentially is
implied is that your region doesn't
necessarily matter to the same value as
the united states region
and you know it's going to be
interesting if that's going to affect
them because
you know
here's the thing first of all shout out
to microsoft nintendo this was a pr
layup
this was like oh they did what
i would love to have been a fly on the
wall when they got because if we found
this at a three in the morning i'd love
for people wake up like
what calvin working over there okay
let's go like like this is one of those
ones when you watch those documentaries
and we look back at it years ago and
they were like they you know you hit up
stories for us they were in the
boardroom and they were waiting for the
price and then the price came and they
go oh they did what and then it's like
say immediately that our price is the
same and that we like literally
microsoft can now position themselves
as the most
value-friendly console of the generation
not only are they giving you a two-skew
approach wherever they get in you know
with the series as a little shocked a
little man you know what i'm saying and
on that
you know on that front then you have
let's be honest you know what i'm saying
it's to me it's not subjective
game pass is probably one of the best
values in gaming i i just feel sorry as
far as what are they giving you day and
day with the games that are coming that
we've seen exactly i'm not it's just
that's just my ball i just feel it it's
not close
no doubt it's absolute you know what i'm
saying so you got that you know we we
talked about the features you guys
talked about kind of like the the the
nickel and diming that that sony was
doing and you know and on the other side
you talk about the features that xbox is
doing you know the quick resume the
smart delivery we all thought those are
buzzwords they actually these features
actually are practical and they're
actually giving value to their
generation so you talk about all that
you talk about the pc you talk about the
cloud stuff that you get in the service
and then it starts to add up
right then it starts what fonz is
alluding to it starts to now
this is the thing if farzin and ken you
guys understand this specifically
we're old enough to understand
that every generation is a clean slate
every generation it doesn't matter how
much you dominated the last generation
especially when you're making some balls
moves like raising the prices exactly
and here's the thing because it's a
clean slate right because we've seen the
extra that is the doll mattress you see
the xbox one yeah
real quick you know what's funny we
always talk about these scenarios it's
like oh that's just as bad as the uh the
xbox one beginning that's just as bad
that maybe not as bad but it's around
there this raising is literally xbox one
launch level stuff look i got to keep it
100 and king you get it you get you get
one need today because thank you guys
appreciate it
don't worry
get the cash out of your shoulder see i
don't like the cash on your shoulder
don't be putting cash on your shoulder
we can put
i want to give you some credit because
week uh first of all week after week you
always find some news that somebody's
doing for salute but anyway
but you know we got to win over there
you will challenge me and you will say
but what is it going to take for you to
to question what's going on with it
right what is it going to take because
it's like you know you don't seem
concerned and my answer to you at the
time was always like look
unlike the ps3 generation i do see some
form of course correction or trying to
adapt even if it's later i would still
see them trying to adapt to certain
things you know i mean and
trying to compete in certain ways that
not that they have to compete exactly
like xbox i don't believe that but i do
see some strides but i have to say this
is when i lean back to attic and i lean
back to fonz and what mr babbitt was
saying is that
after a while
these are the type of moves that add up
when you you raise the price of a
console in the mid generation you you
you kind of parted it seven you wanted a
mid-gen refresh
you puffed they refreshed the price
that's
it is like you know you do that you do
the price you several games then the bad
messaging about you know generations and
and what your true intentions are with a
console then you're remaking remakes and
then this list starts to get bigger
right and then now
you position yourself like these are the
type of things that could cost you a
generation long term right these are the
type of things because we we we all have
it we all admit people can say yes
sony makes some of the best
games there's no question there's no
denying a god of war trailer drops right
now the zeitgeist is back to where they
needed to be and it's a new state of the
state of play i get it but if you look
at it long term right and your
competitor is literally attacking all
your deficiencies and have the war chest
and capital to stay in the mix with now
software studios and games that we
expect to come
now it starts to change the conversation
and that's why i'm a little concerned
for the first time because it's like if
you keep
at some point it doesn't matter how much
cachet you've earned you can lose that
you can we've been we've been argued
that saying they're already starting to
lose right we've seen the nintendo wii
right the one of the most dominant
consoles whether you know whether you
like it or not it was dominant and then
they had a wii u you know
right after we've seen these shifts i'm
not saying yeah was literally the
highest selling platform go to the ps3
right and i'm not saying playstation 45
is automatically going to the gutter but
i'm just saying you start to
make a lot of these missteps and you're
just by a thousand cops right and then
now your competitor is perceived as the
golden child of value
and at the end of the
you know the last point is just that
we we're gonna have to see because
it behooves microsoft now to attack this
weakness
a full filter
and
and like the marketing you know we are
the most valued we got xbox all access
you don't have money we go right now run
out the store
it reminds me a little i got a lot it
does have a little ps3 energy yeah
absolutely
come on
we can't act like it's a superior
product
so we got a page
we gotta separate them
we gotta separate ourselves from how we
do it overnight raise the price real
quick i do want to go around the table
real quick around the round table and i
want to ask you
is this feeling ps3 arrogance to you
let's start with a bad bit
this is still like ps3 arrogance
absolutely
yeah definitely
king oh okay fawns
of course
this is a little bit different
is this kings because it's sodium
texas
let me tell you why this is different
yes
somebody told you in the beginning of
the playstation 3
you need another job
these dudes waited for you to fall
asleep at night with the product in the
store
and tomorrow you got to put in more work
hours
you know what sad king imagine the
people that's been saving up for six
months to buy playstation 5. they're
going to suddenly about to get it with
that next paycheck and then they wake up
to oh it's about to go to 5 50. well man
i gotta wait another whole paycheck yeah
well it's that's the playstation tax you
want the superior product right how you
gonna be superior product and you do the
inferior things you do
it's nuts that little man little man is
pushing y'all to the brink this is what
happens when little man beat you silly
you get delirious you just start raising
prices little man is boxing a little bit
silly this is all little man this is all
little man because if microsoft didn't
put out little man they wouldn't do this
they would not do this they would stay
there the price would be the same will
be none of this inflation stuff so they
said overnight somebody's bright idea
and somebody went along with it they
said how do we separate ourselves from
these dudes because you know y'all
equate more money means a superior
product this is what they think right
this is what's going on
so
if it's 50 more that means the
playstation's hard to get
it's a superior product
it's better than this inferior stuff and
you guys keep falling for it hook line
and sinker shout out to little man
listen
if you're waiting for a playstation stop
right now today don't worry about it the
scalpers got it and when they when they
do actually get a price break cause
y'all waiting for black friday this is
gonna be the first console on black
friday that's gonna be double the price
it's gonna know it's gonna be funny too
man
fifteen hundred
you know it's gonna be funny too
because walmart and then i could just
see them coming out there like
yo let's
right now you 550 i don't know if the
the price increase has happened now but
in certain these countries you got to
think that that's without a forced
bundle once if they do the 550 then
bundle horizon or the next god of war
with it eventually and that sucker is
600 because it's a force bundle because
right now if you look at there's
podcasts out there there's people
literally saying that they wanted a ps5
and they had to buy that horizon bundle
there was no way around it you know
there's a little bit of fluffing on the
numbers you know i'm just being real
with you right there but you know
that is what's going on here and it's
like king said earlier when i was
driving home like that bundle is not a
free bundle they forced you to buy that
game so now you're going to add a 50 on
top of that 550 already happening and
it's going to be a 600 force bundle now
i got more wait there's more
yeah then you got gamestop getting these
things there they're gonna have to add
fifty dollars under their bundles
hey hey hey forte considering you you
work at the the the luxury's a game stop
but what's what's up what's the typical
bundle going there for right now for the
ps5 you know go ahead oh man dang that
700 over here so so the horizon bundle
was
what
six
dollars
[Laughter]
what is it what is it
that bundle was um seven hundred dollars
so so in your personal opinion you're
pretty sure that 50 gonna be added on to
this it's going to be 750. well we ain't
worried about that here in america but
everywhere else yeah
and so like that's the crazy thing
though at the end of the day my god what
is that that's the playstation 5 pro oh
yo
you're ridiculous
hey let's get let's get what they
finished i gotta get four balls though
sure
so this is my last point then i got it i
got to head out y'all but i'll say this
this is a question that's going to have
a a while to answer
because like we see this right here
right now and we're like this is the
this is this is this is probably the
worst move they've done in a long minute
but how is the modern again the typical
consumer actually going to
respond to this when yeah you have game
stops you have walmarts you have targets
doing these outrageous and stupid
bundles for
god knows how much price to art you know
to to to get their their their accessory
i forget what it's called in retail the
tax rate is the attach rate up right and
people are buying them
and so that's the real question is like
we think this sucks yep but the
analytics that things the average
consumer think that's gonna be the key
time going to yeah be the answer and
you're right i again if i'm microsoft
i'm going to these areas and i'm going
to market the cr because if i'm in
germany and we're about to face one of
the the biggest energy crisis in my
nation's history
and i'm seeing a price
up on a playstation well now xbox
microsoft has to do the job of letting
you know
the true value between them
and their competition and if microsoft
and i doubt they're not doing this
it doesn't do that
well that's a huge misstep yeah but to
me at the end of the day
it's gonna be it's gonna take a little
bit of time to find out if this actually
hurts them yes or is this all hyperbole
no that's a great point
if this happened you know
next year where we do have the red falls
at starfields um whatever else have you
yeah this would be a whole different
conversation i think once microsoft has
the games in their arsenal and they're
there they're out they solve their
pipeline whatever
you're going to see a different type of
battle take place i think it's in the
here and now where playstation knows
they could take a chapter out of
nintendo
and raise the price and then hey who
knows once xbox starts getting
competitive maybe they slash the price
by 50 bucks again
exactly and and that's that's the only
problem so again
it i think this is awful i don't like
this one bit right
to the consumers to speak up yeah
i got a worse scenario for you they're
raising the 50 now so later they can act
like it's a price cut back to me
everybody's like give us a pat on the
back oh it helps you out so much
real talk they're gonna do it
i'm gonna break protocol real quick i
gotta get y'all this ball before we bbw
bobby
bobby's out why y'all complaining you
already got playstation 5 and it's not
affecting america playstation 5 still
going beat a goat fake outrage because
it's affecting people it doesn't need to
affect me
for me to care about something right if
it's affecting someone else someone that
wants to get into this ecosystem then
yeah no i want to fight for the consumer
i'm not here to fight for a
multi-billion dollar company i'm not
they're all a you know again they're all
immoral at the end of the day i'm not
here to fight for microsoft i'm not here
to fight for micros
or for sony i'm here to share my
perspective and hopefully fight for the
average folks that just want to play
games and govern them as such you just
earned my respect bit yeah thank you so
much
that's good on you joe's because see we
need more people like you to balance
people like me because i don't care
i want what i want we
for every two addicts that got to be one
big cloud to to evaluate because we're
always going to be i love big clouds
i'm not big clown
actually outside in the public yeah
outside the streets he pulled up on me
so anybody that could pull up on me
he got my respect
bad [ __ ]
bad bit is that that person in the
picket fence fighting for like you know
better paying stuff and i'm the one
going in there like i'm already getting
paid good
i got i got it i got to do two things
one mr bad [ __ ]
plug where you from talk to the people
good to see you back for so i was living
it but we had to get you for a minute
what did you finish out there where can
the five people find what you got going
on sir yeah so you can find me over at
the trophy room a playstation podcast
where each and every thursday me and my
best friend kyle talk about the latest
the greatest all things playstation
again each and every thursday over on
apple podcast over on spotify and you
can check the video version over on the
trophy room show you can find me over at
mr babbitt you can find the show over at
p.s trophy room over there on twitter so
guys thank you all so much for having me
no doubt you know you know it's always
an open invitation for you all
appreciate you love always love it enjoy
your day forte got to get your balls
you've been patient what do you think
about the play 65 price increase
well first of all shout out to a bit um
bad bit you know amazing guys shout out
to the best game show host on the on
youtube my man fines
one quarter of my one-third of my raid
team shout out to you guys yeah you
already know we got to get back up shut
up and the minute always keeps it natty
my friend my bestie
the medic he said daddy hey king buddha
forte
do it in life
i don't even know the genesis of that
but as i lay here in this
money all this sony cash
you know what the problem is that sony
cash looking a little white they got to
bring some of that green background
you're seeing my money looking funny in
the light
when he was in the tub
[Laughter]
stop kick shaving so i was like yo they
wallet anyway 14 how are you feeling
about this thing man yeah man so let's
be okay so
oh man it's it's so many levels to this
especially there's levels to this level
to this man especially being you know
just because we're not affected by it
doesn't mean we don't have a a place to
actually put our opinion on stuff like
this because
you know no it's definitely not because
guess what sony in the in the in the
what was like a thief of the night at 2
am in the morning in america was like
you know what who's the biggest
multimedia market
that will literally have the biggest
problem with this even though it won't
affect them but they're the ones that's
going to take the narrative to a whole
other level right oh isn't that north
america you know what we're going to
drop this at 2 a.m they ain't going to
see this until six hours later and
hopefully hopefully a lot of that blows
over by the end which kind of it did
because it only lasted like a good 12 to
14 hours of like a really huge
conversation but
i just look at this i look at this
company and i'm saying wait a minute so
we got to raise prices on a system never
happened before in the middle of it
until this year for some reason when it
comes to you know shout out to shout out
to your bosses over there at
we started this but me
no comment but we ain't going
to know i respect that that's kind of
where it started at but the biggest
thing for me is
is it the playstation 5
base system wasn't it
profitable
wasn't it they were talking about
profits yeah they were talking about it
that system was already profitable right
yeah so so we took the most profitable
system you had
and then we added 50 bucks to it
we also added 10 to the price of all of
our first party games and basically said
that okay our games are worth this and
we're tied up behind features and stuff
that you got to have in order to um
basically benefit from what the
playstation 5 is giving you so we're
charging you for upgrades on that um
we're also going off and
um raising prices of our old accessories
when it comes to ps4 and saying you know
what those blue and those white and
black controllers that used to cost
59.99 oh no we're gonna make those
things um 64 across the board so it's
like i'm looking at all these different
avenues that playstation has been making
more money on all of their products for
the last year and i'm like so you still
have to make more money on top of what
you're already making
tell me where this disconnect is i don't
i don't understand from a uh just a
consumer standpoint that it's our
responsibility
to make up for the losses that you are
having as a company
for some stuff like that that's that's
where i don't come from it's like just
go ahead go ahead
you know why they create snapchat 550
bucks because they about to lose that
call of duty money oh my god you're
ridiculous ridiculous
finish for today and i got a question
for you then we move on yeah go ahead no
the question i got for you and again i i
listen i hear everybody what they say
my question for y'all is from uh you
know there's a lot of there's a lot of
economic talk going on economics macro
economics tell them about it
but i i will say let's play devil's a
bit so let's just say right and we have
to of the objective on this
i do not agree with this but the thing
is look i want it like we look at
microsoft and we go look you know most
value for valuable consoles we value
friendly console
and you look at sony and then we have to
be honest you know microsoft has this
huge war chest right
you know they can afford to pump this
money in the game fast and buy these
studios and so they can and then you
look at sony as a whole
right and you look at the other
divisions that are not playstation
mm-hmm right
and and now and i know this is where you
i know you love this
we can
is it safe to say right that those other
divisions are not placed the playstation
division division right now is truly the
heart of sodium what drives revenue so
so one can say
that they have to protect this at all
costs because if this fails right
they could be out of here now the last
point i will say in reference to we got
to say in reference to inflate i'm not
an economics major but we have to say
that the us dollar right is probably at
its strongest in comparison to the
others right now euro whatever whatever
like things are more even than in the
past they have ever been so it would
make even more sense to raise it over
here
i'm gonna touch that part so what i'm
gonna say
is i'm gonna say because i'm playing
devil's advocate and you messing up
arguments is that what they could say is
like look you know what yesterday's
price wasn't today's price in the other
regions and now
we may i'm just making up a number i'm
not a man let's say theoretically
they're breaking even they were making a
slight profit over these other regions
now with inflation they break it even so
jim and they take it up to the board is
like yo we got to get this bread so like
we gotta we gotta do something so in
that vein is there any everything i know
it's probably not but is any empathy for
them for you for you to them saying that
in these regions that they can't be
profitable playstation is their soul i
have a revenue stream
i have a question for you dan for you
asking that
when was the last economic crash we had
as a country 2008 2009
what was what was the system that
released around that same time in 2007
that was uh six 599 and 699. playstation
3. and pl playstation quickly within a
year and a half in the middle of that
economic downturn dropped their price by
a hundred to two hundred dollars
so you tell me
how that same company
took a 200 hit back then but now when i
can tell you when economics isn't
nowhere near as bad they're still bad i
got i got one too
i can tell you how they did it okay like
then
sony had to walk man sony actually was
uh number one in the tv market
the only one on sony movies uh division
was definitely out there tearing it up
right sony actually had phones so at
that period of time they had different
pillars where they couldn't make it
yeah
and blu-ray and the blu-ray hold on and
and the blu-ray was taking off so they
made the bet very early on on blu-ray
and that was the cheapest blu-ray in the
market at that period of time once they
dropped that price down and they were
able to capitalize on that because at
that point in time um
hd dvd had lost the battle by that's
true they paid direct correct back yeah
so they made the correct call so they
was able to take the price hit right now
they don't have that advantage in the
box that separates them from the direct
competitor which is microsoft as far as
a blu-ray player or hdd anything they
don't have anything in the box that they
set for a fast fast ssd
and it's not fast enough to outrun them
prices
but that's that's the only thing that
they have in the box right they have the
inferior box right now at that point in
time they had a superior box with
superior tech that was hard to um i
don't know i got one last one but now
they have an inferior box with just a
fast ssd out there and they don't have
nothing else to pull from so that's the
only reason why they raise the price
that's it that's okay and they're gonna
give it back to you i just want to say
and also we have to admit that in the
game business hardware is not the seller
generally they you take a hit as a
manufacturer on hallway and your thought
is to get it back on software so i don't
know what their numbers are but let's
say theoretically let's just say in your
defense forte you're right to the core
they just and i'm not i'm not damage
control they did say prior they're
making good money they're making profit
right profits
i'm not going to i'm not going to
sugarcoat that i'm not going to
sugarcoat that but what it could but my
opinion what could be right is you're
making less money and you're still over
or you break it even and now you're
trying to keep where you where you at oh
yeah we're going to shut this down even
more
let me say something real quick before
you go on your rant
i feel like it has less to do with the
what was going on
in the industry over there at that time
and i think it has more to do back then
they they lowered it because it was the
ps3 because they were competing because
they weren't on top at the time now
they're on top people are going out
there going to ebay buying consoles for
800 plus dollars like they see the
demand and they're like look people only
pay 800 on ebay they're going to be
paying 35.50
until my point because i'm being
corporate card today you know what i
mean
the market demands that the the market
says
they willing to pay so why are you
hating on me trying to get my bag
it's the walker says it don't matter we
put 70 yeah
we're not hating on sony wanting to make
more money we're hating on sony it
doesn't make sense what they're doing
it's like
but it makes sense to the wallet but if
it was truly about finances
if if it was truly about finances then
they would have they would have did that
america too like that wasn't it
drop off more playstations now all of a
sudden magically more playstations pop
up
nah man this this oh no we got breakfast
oh
we're taking you to school on wednesday
salute lawrence we're going to macro
macro economics one-on-one
[Music]
wish i got a a year oh
okay all right let's go let's go for it
real quick before we go i think it's
just about
they're getting that pia they feel like
they could do whatever they want
and no one's gonna read it's like i said
like
phil spencer was trending for three days
on something on an interview
and then raising prices
only got people's attention for a day no
one's talking about it now
with that mindset
all right well hold up with that mindset
why would playstation not do it like
it's just like look like nowhere clearly
you don't see ign you don't see none of
them i already told you earlier it's
because dummies will pay for it
it's that simple people are going to
continue to pay
we know
that aren't bringing it up so you
clearly got a lot of media coverage in
in positive ways
you you no it's not it's not that it's
just like look let's call it how it is
no one's talking about it anymore there
was no videos made about this sony knows
we are good right now it don't matter
what we do we gonna do whatever we want
and you guys are gonna bend the knee
because we playstations
if you want
is affecting people to criticize is that
i'm applying they're on drugs right now
that's the one
you know
they could do whatever they want but
guess what nintendo thought they could
do whatever they want it took them a
whole generation to fix that no doubt
playstation thought they could on the
ps2 took them a whole generation to fix
that xbox was at the height of a power
on the 360. took a whole generation to
fix that
you could sit here and go in into these
conversations with as much arrogance and
i see brapping they supply and demand
you can say all that stuff you want it
doesn't matter what you sell them for it
matters on what is going to influence
the market that you're currently doing
on and we thought the 360 was at the
height of the power no one gets guess
what the xbox one destroyed the brand it
took them an entire generation to
recover from that because they felt like
they could do whatever they wanted to
who did it oh who are you oh a
addict
ominous maximus are real you know what's
funny you know what's funny people want
to sit there and they want to talk about
price matters that's the reason the ps4
and xbox one was like this that hundred
dollar difference addict it matters but
people acting like fifty dollar
difference isn't mattering at all it's
always okay if it's on one side but when
you put the spell out on the other
they're like supply and demand we gotta
get this bull snap out of this chat
because you guys are capping see what
you just go crap
be nice let's be respectful
let's go
no and therefore they have one quick
thing and then therefore take it for
granted oh yeah i got to get out of here
because i gotta get oh yeah you gotta
show the game talk loudly yeah i i gotta
get stuff ready and everything but oh um
before i go just really quick i wanted
to say that uh about this situation yes
cognito to answer your question earlier
when you were asking you know forte uh
and us basically about you know would i
have any empathy for the company because
you're not making as much money or
you're breaking even
hell no i ain't got a
billion billions of dollar corporations
i don't give a damn i care about my own
damn wallet i'm a consumer at the end of
the day i care about my price not your
price i don't care what you're making on
the bottom end i care about where my
wallet is going what i'm paying for and
that's all anybody in this audience
should care for you shouldn't care about
macroeconomics you shouldn't care about
their wallets you shouldn't care about
any of that stuff this is why i argue
with you brad by the way respectfully uh
i think you defend it way too much buddy
way too much these corporations are
making hand and fist money over you know
just crazy amounts of money
um it's insane that people would defend
this stuff but i'll say this um just to
touch on a little bit about what we were
talking about earlier them trying to get
into film tv and do all this other stuff
because they have those divisions to do
so so they can take some of these
popular ip and try to gain an audience
somewhere else i get that i get that but
feed your gamers feed your gamers first
we don't need to be feeding another
medium we need to be feeding gamers you
are playstation these ipa playstation
games create these sequels that people
want not tv shows not films and if
you're going to make these films
these films
make it to where
uh
what do you call it i'm sorry somebody
just right you're good but if you if you
nobody walked into the arcade but if you
yeah exactly but if you make these but
if you make these films and stuff you
have to continue to feed the gamers i'm
sorry it's just you have to do that and
there's one reason why they do
they want to make these movies though
because it's quicker money
these movies only take one to two years
to make yes they are very expensive to
make even more expensive than some of
their games however the profits return
quicker that is the reason why they want
to make these ip into movies that in
film film is even quicker than that you
heard it here folks fawns and they
leaving the gaming industry
you heard it here they are doing this to
try to make a quick buck because they're
still trying to earn money and get more
revenue in the old world ways
they want
that's right only right now is
begrudgingly moving into a different
space that they don't want to in this
industry
so they're trying to get other
to to grasp at other avenues that they
do have and make more money there like
their business with the film and tv but
they don't want to be moving into this
service based stuff they're being forced
to that's the way i feel that it is with
them that's why they don't want to put
their games in their day and date and
all that stuff because
number one they can't afford it right
now but number two they don't want to
really do this right now they don't want
to do it ever but they know it's kind of
inevitable so they've got to be making
money wherever they can right now
sony is worried i don't care what
anybody says out there
stony is worried that is why they didn't
uh raise the price here in america
because xbox is real competition here in
america
sorry it's just the way it is
um that that is one and it's a lot of
their market too so that's why i said if
it was really about inflation and
finances they wouldn't have cared look
we're still doing good there let's raise
the prices they looked at look let's
raise it where we can that makes sense
where we won't get the key distinction
for y'all is is the u.s exclusion from
because to me if it was about inflation
of money they would have cared like look
we got to survive that's what this is
about surviving this doesn't seem like
it's about surviving it seems like what
can we get off all one on the breaks of
the world and make money
you know what somebody in the shop said
somebody in the chat said that uncharted
uh didn't make money no it did uh
uncharted only costs 120 million to make
which is a lot but it returned 410
million at the box office who knows what
they're getting uh from netflix but i'm
just saying
it's it's it's quick cash for them it's
easy to make revenue for them like this
and if they take strong ip from their
games division and make them into movies
they can turn a profit that's what
they're doing i get that i understand
that but feed your gamers first that's
all i gotta say look fine i'm gonna need
you right there hold on let me get farts
out of here correctly you can find me at
fonz gaming i'll be doing my show in uh
just a couple hours with colt eastwood
today absolutely uh we'll be talking
more about this stuff and other things
as well gamescom all that stuff we're
going to be talking about a lot of cool
stuff don't talk about that dumb [ __ ]
i'm into the show
i like that show sir
the next time i'm in the bay when i have
more time
brother so our father was not having
limited time ignored me interesting the
funds give me this give me the business
i got to hollywood travis
when you leave
to go and put your redirects and put and
put us as a as approved for you
no doubt no doubt
foss thank you brother no because i'd
like to send all right i'd like to send
the podcast to you but i can't do it
unless you put us as an authorized
reader authorize me directly yeah forte
final point that we got a movie
no yeah yeah i mean the biggest thing
for me is it's like
youtube it baby no so the biggest thing
for me it mostly just comes back to i
just don't understand the move
i mean i understand why they're doing it
it just doesn't make it right because
they're making me put the money down
they're making so much money
king is making king king the head of
playstation you're making so much money
in uh in all these different avenues you
know you don't allow right listen king
you don't allow king you need a
playstation you do not allow retailers
to sell any of your digital product you
don't allow us to say yes
we have to send them to your we have to
give them point cards that we basically
make no money off of nothing send them
to your store so you get 100 profit off
of everything that's falling off that
system guess what you also just
announced that uh over the last year
your um digital to physical ratio just
went up to eighty percent so you need to
tell me that we leave in the market
listen you had a 20 year over year rank
up i mean markup over there so
that's that's profit you don't have to
buy you don't have to buy are you
manufacturing for cases
you don't have to you don't have to pay
for um manufacturing of disc anymore
you have to do any of that stuff you
just have to have a person go to your
marketplace and pay you 70 bucks uh-huh
you get full profit of all your friends
all right let me tell you why the prices
is raised here
because you guys may not understand
exactly why because y'all brought a 5
billion dollar lawsuit against them
oh this is in preparation for the
lawsuit we are not paying a nickel
you are
50 go ahead 4k i do apologize for that
no you're fine
like i said the general just ultimately
comes back to it's it's something that
just needs to be spoken about because we
have a voice to say it it doesn't affect
us directly
but playstation is out of pocket for
this one because they didn't have to do
you didn't have to do king take your
leprechaun hat off you ain't have to do
this bro let me tell you something this
is the color of money here
all right nobody gonna do that so you're
trying to match the so that had this so
you trying to get your money to finally
match the color of that hat
let me tell you something my money don't
look funny to you this is digital cash
this is digital cash all right so when
you go to the store and you're paying
the same price that they're paying a
story but you get no package you don't
get nothing you actually you don't even
get the rights to the game because if i
shut off the server
full price in the store full price at
home baby that's how we do it and you're
going to buck up buckaroo
don't be [ __ ] nothing
[Music]
but king what happens if i don't have
half the money for it if you don't got
it you can't play hey this is pay for
play here
if you are not on the pay-per-view list
you're not inside man and i'm going to
tell you right now oh hold
realities is it the same as excusing or
acceptance of unfortunately when one
says the sky is blue the community yells
why are you defending this guy is blue
oh why do you keep repeating the same
stuff you've been saying for years bro
that's what i want to know why don't you
tell me that brad tell me why you've
been saying the same three analogies for
the past 10 years when you tell me that
then we'll address your
microsoft would have raised the price
brad would not be saying that see brap
right now see this is where we call
hypocrisy
let me tell you the level of hypocrisy
this is the reason why i call you
flip-flop let me tell you let me tell
you flip-flop
i got mad love for you but you're
letting your stuff show now let me tell
you man if this
was actually microsoft doing this you
will be outraged this with a fake
outrage come out and you'll be sitting
here talking about how could they do
this to us he'd have a bripe ramp right
now but brad
we got you we got you man this is it
so the best thing for you to do is just
fall back brother
fall back don't buck up on this one this
one is not a fight you can win sir you
know the funny thing is that sony does
stuff like that because people like you
bro
but the funny thing is
stuck in the middle yeah the funny thing
is if microsoft does something like this
they would be like we could understand
the economics of why you're doing it but
they'll be like well how are you going
to raise the price on something that you
ain't got no gains for it'll come back
to that all right listen shout out to
brad no consumer
wants or cares for price increases see
he said it he just said he said why are
you doing everything
see all i want to know brad
is was there a brap rant for this
have you made such a big outlaws with
this because phil spencer you've
literally made like 18 rat brap ramps
over phil spencer comments where's the
ramp for this
where is the conversation around this
where is the we got to talk about this
this is this is this is
microsoft does something it's an issue
it's on fire the world's unrolling sony
does something it's just business that's
what they had to do i don't know what to
tell you guys you guys know business i
know business apparently so you know
what definitely so going so go so going
forward says brap wants to take me to
take me to the carpet on on wednesday
you're going so just just i'm just i'm
announcing it right here on iop
for future notice
all of the transactions that brap get
done through me at my at my store that
he likes to shop
no no although you know what there is a
fifty dollar surcharge
oh that's what we're doing because the
price of a brick went up no you know
what you know
the price the prices just went up you
know this is hard out here you know my
time is valuable
i got to go to the post office inflation
is up
or his request that's the box it put you
down oh my god money into shipping that
stuff you know what the price just went
up 50 bucks
you know so you know not just a one
product on everything i ship to you so
um let's just let you know sir you're
you're lighting your thought process
with okay
so look we're gonna move on and get off
of
this
are you gonna be paying him that extra
money for that sony wallet that you love
you love about sewing his wallet why
don't you the next time you see that
representative that you have on the just
pass the 59th just past the 50 because
you got to be nice to that ecosystem
that
clearly you know something's going on we
don't know about so just just pass that
50 when you buy that next ps5 just pay
them an extra hundred sony good you
don't care sony good give them that
extra hundred dollars so moving on to
the next topic and um yeah super chats
let's get those let's do that um
your most demanding day and i do
apologize for being part of the message
because i got y'all i'm ridiculous
you see what you did oh my god let's get
these super chats um
showed oh hold on
shout out is that oh i don't even see
that i'll break protocol because i've
never seen a super chat here is that
next gen 720 with a two hour super chat
brat wants to be me without the success
oh my lord here we go this is shout out
to a shout out to my man you know what i
support that message salute salute to
everybody here let's just be nice oh
free kelly's in there oh i got so super
chance to get through all right listen
guys if we can get up to 700 likes uh
attic and i have something special for
you guys this labor day weekend all
right so let's 700 likes just hit that
like seven hundred likes man all right
neither 700 likes or 15 members
either one of those i'm gonna have to
read some of them again because i don't
know where i had stopped off so last
i'll remember was um donald taco the
king and his loyal surgeons xbox podcast
is definitely gonna be fine today five
hour super chat uh chaos actual final
super chat sci we know things are hard
for you and we're here to add to it
jay hulk fought out super chat hey now
no kick shaving you talk about the
dominating toy we may never relate to
the pleasure of sony fanboy experiences
from being financially dominated but
it's not our place to show oh my god
flame 5 super chat to the people who
live in the us and own a playstation 5
already please do not speak for the
detriment of people living in countries
this is affecting thanks
don otaku 2 super chat not only is the
box unstable the price is on too wow
that was that was balls hard shady 10
super chat xbox does well as canada as
us so the idea it's about xbox's market
performance in the us may not be true i
think it is more about the narrative
when we talk about prices it's always in
the us interesting crazy horse five
dollar super chat you could only find
playstation 5 bundles at 549 dollars in
the us so technically the prices are up
in the usa forte is that true yeah
yeah they are the bundle oh i didn't do
that that's what i was just saying like
right now the only bundle you can find
is the horizon bundle they have
artificially raised that
in the next two years they say horizon
so 10 million because seven million
people wanted to get the console are you
talking about the same thing he did with
spider-man miles morales when they said
that every place yeah you mean every
game that's sold god of war did it they
did it with uncharted what you know xbox
did it plenty they did it with uh gears
of war five gears of war four they did
it with a few games but it's just like
i will call out xbox for their nonsense
it's like look like you you did what you
did to get those numbers up you didn't
really sell them because i got a gears
of war fought for and i sold it i didn't
play it i already had the game but just
like i will call that out it's like look
like that game sold well but those are a
little fluffy it's a little fluffy it's
not exactly sales it's like
but it seems like when it comes to
playstation people just want to act like
they legitly sold 10 million plus of a
game no there's probably six seven
million of those on a bundle that's the
reason that they went up and that's
probably why jim ryan says what what
what does dim right say yesterday's
price is not today's price what else
does he say
i gotta read this super chat he says
you're not enough here we go
stop i miss you brother oh my god
tyson
boo hi joe uh australian 799 to play
call of duty online on a playstation 5
will cost you over wow over one thousand
dollars in australia when card is on
game pass with a family plan and series
s it'll be half that price value salute
to australia in the house oh oh i got it
let me get it i got it i got it free
i'll take the one after that take it out
of that free r kelly five dollar super
chat kang
supply and demand sony moving ps5 like
hot cakes keep renting on xbox
man we got another bra
supply and demand sony moving
playstation 5's out here like hot cakes
keep written on xbox
trying to defend it kels yeah listen
kels i understand your time is limited
and and the fact that your money is
limited you got like 10 minutes on the
pc before they put them back to the
background
yo i'm sorry
r kelly that kind of jew that knows
where all the blind spots are in prison
wow
split difference two dollar super chat
cows don't start and it won't be don't
start no there won't be none you famous
we got a two dollar superchat from danny
passion official buying in a game
exclusive content that sucks i agree
with them i don't like when people do
that i prefer timed exclusives or
full-blown exclusives before you start
locking sections of the game down to
another console we got a five a 10 00
shot from don otaku
next gen upgrades ten dollars first
party game seventy dollars lesson
subscription service eighteen dollars a
month late late fee for not having a p.s
yo twenty to fifty dollars a month sony
demanding its fans to do nothing but
praise
priceless
gamonomics with the hundred dollar i
forget uh rupee uh sony actually saved
me money by doing this because i ain't
buying a playstation 5 anymore
i already have a pc
i'll wait two years for the exclusives
to get there
fat boy horror five pounds super chat
lord [ __ ] mark dara on the age channel
confirmed that mass defect two was that
goat in his face in his face did he do
it oh i gotta record that show
we gotta find out from don utaku there's
no sony first party game this shin that
didn't launch with some speculation and
now they have a weaker more expensive
console ps5 going out sad you know what
i'm gonna add a little bit words to you
for you don't talk ps4 going out real
sad messy
okay
good
ten dollar super chat from goat doctor
uh okay
we need to stop saying other companies
started seventy dollar games when it was
apple epic dog when it was in the apple
epic dog sony asked them to raise to 90
dollars and they said no way it's too
much sony asked for this we got a 10
super chat from uh from target shanee
good thing is that there is competition
for sony consumers win when fierce
competition drives up value and drives
down cost
about that parking
sony is doing the opposite
but it's still being forced to add more
value we got to find out from donataku
and we're not going to talk about
multiplayer games of the years for two
three all right
we getting on sony today
like that nintendo slanted that uh mr
vat was giving him rg viper x five
dollar super chat series s is now ten
dollars cheaper on xbox website oh wow i
didn't know that right now sony just
lost this generation no ps6 after this
no doubt raiden blade five power super
chat my girl had no interest in halo she
watched the tv show and hungry for more
she is playing on my account the more
games that jumps movie opens up to the
fans yeah that's true no doubt rate and
blade again five pound super chat king
my bro anyone champion the price hike
our brainless have overdosed on that
playstation kool-aid it's too late for
them and the ign and kotaku are hiding
okay let me get something real quick
because it was deleted the wise old
gamer had a five dollar super chat it
said
my super chat should have been i got a
second job for playstation for my
playstation 3 do i need a third job now
did you accidentally delete that or did
a mod delete your super chat tell us
what happened in the comment section don
otaku ten dollars stop comparing sony to
nintendo when the 3ds was failing they
dropped the price and gave early buyers
20 20 games for free iwata cut his own
salary 50 because the wii u bombed
they're not the same
ever born saga two dollar super chat but
but micro economics oh my god jesus we
got we gotta find out superstars from
alvin yeah horizon forbidden west is on
its way to being the most fraud alert 20
million seller in history you know what
i think you're on to something i'll
think you're on to something messy
august augusto zanco brazil i believe uh
15 and uh gang pass and series s is the
best value in gaming right now in brazil
wow so look at brazil the premium
consoles even if converted between real
and dollar it's 908 you wow i hope
there's 108 for most brazilian the cost
of consoles and games is unsustainable
that is huge shout out to brazil for
giving us some information
we got a two dollar spiritual from god's
hitman bang bang
he's not he's not he's not my hit man
he's god
make sure you like and share this
podcast
hit that like button let's get that over
700 fonts i see you in the chat make
sure we on your redirect list that's all
i'm saying
okay you got it yeah reading flight with
the five super chat i don't know what
currency that's let's talk ps5 digital
didn't make okay let's talk ps5 digital
did make less than 100k when uh then
start making them telling you all this
if card lands on the switch ps5 gin is
almost over
i have never seen a digital in person
ever i'm sure forte has 14 just out of
curiosity how many digitals come through
gamestop like like new and used
how many digital ps5s come through
gamestop your gamestop digital or used
oh shoot
way more of the physical one would you
say it's like a two to one kind of thing
like three to one four to one okay let
me get uh
bobby i got you already all dirt
griggity unless you read there
that's the home you gotta find out super
draft from dirt greggy i've never seen
an adjustable rate console before jim
boy is making history no doubt donataku
this really solidifies find out which
chat that sony wanted to price the
playstation 5 higher at launch but xbox
went 500 first and they couldn't go
higher he might have a point there he
might have a point there shout out two
dollars
got this yeah shout out to my god dj
orals i'll be careful whoa whoa whoa
whoa
hey bestie
absolutely five super chat from braden
blade anyone in the chat supporting the
hike is still a man child we are all
gamers around the world we are all
affected to s so stop about the fake
outrage
selfish you hear that brat
time dj two dollar super chat let's get
an article
how you using that classic
super chat from retro rich i love sony
but i honestly feel like the fun's been
drained out of the brand this gin
microsoft needs to advertise better here
in the uk with clear messaging
definitely agree with you no doubt
splitting difference can't say this
movie saw five out of chat forte looking
like the price hikes on the playstations
have been hard on him trying to sell
them in the store all the customers
asking why they cost so much okay okay
yes i know i got these shout out to rap
5.7 chad forte we take you to school on
wednesday salute lords no doubt
raiden blade two pounds super chat sony
gets acquired goodbye spider-man and
wolverine oh okay that's not true
brap two dollar super chat you now have
an f forte for this wednesday show in
the thing you beautiful don't you love
how he don't you love how he tells you
forte someone that works in the industry
how the industry works before takes
beauty but he's doing something raining
blade uh two pound super chat height
lovers are
hike lovers are kool-aid drinkers drink
up i'm assuming those are horses emoji
um brad podcast shout out to the brad 10
hour super chat expand explain oh yeah i
read this one explaining economic
realities isn't the same as excuses no
acceptance of unfortunately when one
says the sky is blue the community yells
why are you defending this guy being
blue we got a two dollar uh no go for it
oh yeah
oh yeah
i told him i already passed that
gsd getting stuff done sony sounds like
tv tv tv wow
two dollar super chat from uh from
raiden blade yeah brap is the kool-aid
drinker drink up bro
wow
two dollar super chat from next gen 720
rep wants to be me without the success
yeah we said all right so are we all the
way quarter i think because now no we
haven't oh god oh
god damn you got to refresh sorry
all right you help me on a refresh you
go get a request
i can't see members to look for members
all right i got you why found out that
the ps
pro price increase now she's changing me
uh changing charging me extra as well
she told me cash or
no
no one writes for me
wow
we got a two dollar super trap from rd
don't forget mooch he's been on this
sony defense nice we got a two dollar
supercharger from uh lord metro
uh sony's wedding and bungie was pricey
they need money
let's see okay necromancer zelle five
dollar super chat still waiting on [ __ ]
to join in with the messiness i'm good
y'all got that guy got a five dollar
super chat from donald see carl can sit
back because me and king are messing oh
yeah clearly we got five dollars should
we chat from dollar to talk every 20
million seller from ps has been bundled
with the console they have never hit
that number without patching it in
unlike nintendo facts i will say that
nintendo don't care about your feelings
they're going to bundle nothing look
you'll get that 300 console the rest of
the time but you're going to pay for
every one of those games outside like
they'll occasionally like bundle a mario
kart occasionally
uh i gotta respect them for that uh you
know because because they they they
really sit on their ips they're like
they're gonna sell we don't need to
bundle them
i'm gonna butcher your name if i want to
man it is what it is
scott yeah skyline i'm just calling you
skyline fam we got to find out the troop
trap from skyline cap brapping for saudi
for the same he admitted he used to cap
for xbox no honor be nice you know what
i'm i'm gonna keep my mouth shut we got
a two hour super shot from bunty please
talk about the price in india not the
same talk about the price i don't know
what he means by that uh oh yeah because
they they said there was a slight
adjustment on the xboxes one we talked i
talked about it on unlocked destiny
brought it up there was a slight
adjustment for xbox and india i believe
that's a bunch he's saying he's saying
it's not to say
and then we got a two super chat from
spartan ghost that attic
uh
r kelly part was a double montana
probably butcher that we're gonna move
right past that how did sony gross 36
billion in profit yet they are blaming
the economy wouldn't you lower the the
uh the price why would
the economy be your excuse to raise the
price yet you raise it worldwide except
the u.s um last one check we are uh
cautionably impacted too okay last time
i checked we are calling
suicide kings member for 22 months put
the crest in the chat lord silva jim
ryan to horse emoji stand back and stand
by all right salute you got the bandage
mcdickens let's see what she saw
you go for it i got it um yeah all right
so let's go apollo cooper two dollar
super chat you shouldn't need a group of
investors for one ps5 all right uh tyson
buhajo australian 799 first it was
jamaican jim now it's texan money gym
what's next magician jim since he's
hypnotized everyone and paying more for
for nothing extra oh my lord
finally with jack flame playstation
sorry y'all but we can't keep the prices
the same we gotta buy bungee for three
billion so we can give you guys real
jack at home
that's
ambassador well that's your fault y'all
shouldn't that told y'all should've told
bungie that hey we want to have your
game we don't want the game to be
everywhere but you know bungie wrote
that check not really sunny no turtles
should die follow us good afternoon
everyone congrats on your podcast online
thank you brother sony is like destiny
repeating the same thing they did with
ps3 when it was six hundred dollars wow
shout out to the homie lawsongaming.net
own rgt podcast the legend big cloud
gaming member for 18 months it amazes me
how many college degrees these shills
have when capping for playstation we
went from thermodynamics
business and now economics damn it
are you implied that there's a motive
behind it
i skipped yours i am sorry i'm going
back oh there we go you're right so
finally super chat sony also had a new
class action lawsuit filed against them
in the uk because sony doesn't allow
digital games to be sold on a
third-party store that is true i did see
that brother thank you for that and we
are caught up i got to move on cause
y'all are really generous and super cool
today but the show can't be six hours i
apologize so um look we gotta talk i am
we are literally about to get ready to
leave great lakes oh okay you think oh
no you'll be a bit brother you're good
all right so um look i just thought this
was interesting i want to shout out the
legendary chess corden from windows
central he broke this almost kind of out
it was the first to break it xbox family
plan so um
a couple of weeks back he had uh talked
about that xbox was working on a family
plan for his gaming subscription service
game pass he later confirmed microsoft
confirmed it that it would um exist it
has allows up to five users to share one
xbox games past subscription within the
same company and then uh yeah it does it
also includes users not within your
household and the the outlet that broke
uh broke it i can't pronounce agramente
lumia may have discovered that the
official family which now reads french a
branding which now reads friends and
family so pretty much basically what
they're saying is um
you're going to be able to use multiple
uh people on this service and um yeah
it's it's something that they're
breaking right now for about twenty five
thousand areas so the expected price of
uh game pass friends and family clocks
in around 25 which will vary by region
and up to five users will get it xbox
game pass ultimate as a result of this
plan and service and um they're also
gonna get pc game pass cloud gaming the
phones the web the net all that stuff
and it also includes xbox live gold for
multiplayer access so this was an
interesting announcement i thought the
timing was was also interesting so what
do we think let's start with true lord
forte if you're not on the phone if
you're here yeah forte man what do you
think about this at the the plan itself
and then obviously the timing and
conjunction what's been going on with
the economic stuff yeah man uh first of
all this needs to happen soon because
i'm tired of paying for multiple xbox
xbox game pass accounts in my own house
um
but um yeah it's really interesting that
the timing of this how it actually
happened and stuff but
this is just another way of microsoft
just trying to bring value to everyone
else when everyone else is like raising
prices they're saying no we're trying to
find a way to give you more for less
money
and yeah i mean that's that's one of the
staples of being a trillion dollar
company that makes their money in so
many different places that they can find
a way to give back to their uh their
community now let's don't get it twisted
this ain't gonna be something that's
gonna last forever sooner or later this
stuff is gonna go up but i always look
at this as a as a as a great selling
point to get people into the ecosystem
yeah and then once you get a you you hit
that max number that you're trying to
hit that's when you start you know
incrementally raising prices and stuff
and i think everybody kind of
understands that nobody really complains
about their netflix account being well
some people do
oh i definitely complained about it
hitting 20. i didn't care when they hit
14. i didn't really care when it hit 50
20
but when they hit 20 i was like yo
what's really going on here
you know
listen the only thing that saved them
for me is the fact that i literally
split that with somebody my little
brother so it's like it doesn't hit me
all the way but everybody's not in that
situation so
as much money as i can get back from the
things that i enjoy the most which is
gaming is always an amazing thing so
this can't happen fast enough but it's
just it's very interesting how all of
these different things align themselves
as you hear bad news somewhere else you
hear good news anywhere somewhere else
and that's how it was all last
generation whenever xbox made them a
step in a misstep playstation was right
there with the shovel
shut days with the shovels like okay we
bought that we about to help dig this
grave a little bit yeah
and what's going on right now you know
xbox playstation's over there raising
prices and then you got nintendo coming
out saying this you got xbox coming out
saying they doing this when the whole
regulation thing started happening and
and playstation was saying we need call
of duty and all the rest of the
developers is like that don't affect us
you mean when sony was snitching yeah
when sony was out there stitching
everybody else because you got to say it
how they did it yeah they said
oh my god
no so so ultimately all this stuff comes
back around and sony it's like i always
tell people this people
sony needed somebody like jim ryan
because jim ryan right at the ship and
we can't take that away from he took one
of their worst performing areas of
playstation in the european market and
made it the most profitable yes
at the detriment of the japanese market
at the detriment of the joshua means
market but the biggest thing is i said i
said listen he is now the c he is the
head of playstation now
he is a money motivated individual
that's going to make money motivated
decisions that's why you're getting your
games on pc now that's why you're seeing
price hikes and stuff like this because
no matter what happens playstation needs
to be profitable yep right so with so
when you contrast that and we always
talk about with xbox
when is the when is the avalanche going
to fall when is that avalanche of all of
these games releasing on the platform
when is that avalanche of just the value
proposition where you literally have to
make a decision like do i want to pay 70
bucks for a call of duty on playstation
or do i want to just get xbox game pass
not only for myself but for my entire
family or ecosystem of gamers that i
like to play games with maybe i want to
get all of my raid teams on my actual um
my family plan so i can say yo this is
the ray team family plan all of our
games are paid for we good maybe that's
something i want to do and then that
just brings more value to the um to the
ecosystem and it makes microsoft stand
out even more uh so that's the thing
that i take from this but it ain't
looking good for everybody else out here
especially when these games start
releasing because uncle phil he out here
making moves and people keep saying that
he's been letting people down but the
plan has always been fix the ecosystem
fix the system fix xbox live now they're
working on the games and the games we
know are coming but they still have some
background stuff they need to do when it
comes to the overall ecosystem of their
services and that's what they're
rounding it to form right now no doubt i
think that's why
i got to see the games like people sit
there and say oh you know
it's been years and to a point i agree
with them it's been years since we've
seen these games and right you know i do
feel like we should have seen something
from them even if it was like you know
small increments of gameplay but i can't
go in until i start seeing the results
of these studios now when we start
seeing the results of the studios
that's why you don't see me going too
much like management issues i feel like
some studios need to be on a corrected
path but i don't think the management of
xbox is in a bad place i think right now
you got some studios being little rebels
but i think for the vast majority of the
of the stable works correctly
now once we start seeing the gains if we
see the next obsidian game and avow it
isn't where it's supposed to be then we
can have a conversation if we see you
know ninja theory and how blade 2 is
where it's supposed then we can have
that conversation but i feel like we
could talk all we want
but
we've already waited how many years four
or five might as well just wait the
extra year year and a half till we
actually start seeing the star fields
the evolved the hellblade twos
after those then i'm up to having
should the management change right
now
real quick i do want to um akw thank you
brother he he uh took i guess we missed
man did go mcdicken shout out then with
the follow-up chat he's reading the
super chat that we missed with the
playstation 5 increase jim ryan told the
sony fan base try to relax your
oh wow
hey okay certain body part shout out to
oh no it's alex sulu salute you already
know um lord king
what are you thinking man about this um
yeah at the time microsoft heard that uh
sony was raising prices and they've been
trying to do it they've raised the game
prices and they've been charging you
nickel and diming you uh they put heptic
feedback and all this other stuff and
it's around music air stuff and
then they charge you for it and
they're sustained
and to to get a ssd you have to buy ssd
and then you got to rip the wings off
and you got to slide something inside
and it's not find something inside paul
yeah well the whole system is paused the
whole system is positive it's cold it's
what it do they remove heat sinks then
charge you more well
microsoft said well we made a ton of
money
and let me show you sony how you pass it
on to
the consumer
thank you microsoft
i really appreciate that with this game
pass family plan
this is how it falls right back on your
neck
right you see you sat there you dudes
was capping
and they changed the team leader they
changed the coach
and y'all sitting there thinking it's
the same team now they running the
triangle offense and nobody in that play
triangle
[ __ ]
this they hired phil and put them on the
knicks this is exactly what happened
remember what they got oh
jackson
michael jordan the triangle offense all
over again it was the most disastrous
seasons we've ever had as me being a
knick fan it was most destructive most
and this is y'all this is right now so
you got the money man he raised europe
and destroyed japan destroyed it right
bill went over to japan and he's raising
it right
so right now
the value is here the value is in the
fact of game pass i told you game pass
was the platform
you guys are sitting in there no man the
console is the platform first of all
if you get a samsung 2022 television
right now game pass is in there game
pass is the platform
right now if you have this family plan
you have a tv
a shout out to paris said first of all
your first problem is being a dick fan
chad paris yeah i hear you i got i'm a
jet fan too so there you go there's a
lot of pain it's a lot of pain let me
just
speak in another language continue oh
now
i'm just saying
five people yes that turns five that
turns game pass ultimate into five
dollars yeah a month game pass ultimate
five dollars
right
that playstation joint is 18
for one guy
it's one guy with no day and date
nothing like
yo
these guys have actively taken cash
they said yo
so now that we got all this money
what are we gonna do are we gonna invest
all this money into ips that we could
put inside our systems hell no
here
take that and go block them
go block what gamepad exclusives what
are we doing here's another one because
game passes out here tearing it up and
we ain't got nothing that can compete
with that we just don't shut up
i just told you to get coffee that said
i ain't asked for your opinions so uh
what i want you to do with this right
now we hear that hogwarts is coming out
i want a dungeon for us
[Music]
exclusive timed exclusives
and we're gonna have it for a little bit
all right uh they just went brought abk
they're going for abk all right uh we
got three billion right here get bungee
oh she don't want she she want to be
with everybody
make it happen
go sleep on the streets whatever
down for that
action we just need her expertise that's
all we just need her around show face
yo
this bed is ridiculous right now
you guys this this is becoming
disgusting game pass ultimate five
dollars
you can get for your broke friends if
you want a ball right if you want a ball
let me show you micro economics
yo you can teach the costs now
this is four months
you can get for your broke friends and
you can ball out for four months with
them on game pass you can be a baller
now if you got two
this is eight months okay and you can
become the king or or or king that or or
that that's two separate family plans
you could play with even more friends
this and this is for the dude this is
for the dude all right you you you want
to be big willie right you got two
houses
you got two households i take care of
this family you gotta take care
promiscuous
you're gonna start going to the
courtrooms and they're gonna be like i
pay game pass and family plan for all my
it's going to be included in your child
support payment yo
you got you got four kids and yourself
just i i don't i don't want to hear you
don't have another kid you have to throw
yourself out of your own family planning
let me break it down break it down break
it down
since you dudes want to do
microeconomics right
sony raised it by fifty dollars
that's eight months
right there
oh whoa
excuse me that's two months
right there because i'm still worried
about these 100 i'm looking at this
money
so what's in the chat xbox child support
plan
family
game pass so if microsoft was to do that
y'all be going crazy but microsoft said
we're going to save you some money
because in my household alone
i got two daughters
my son and myself
that's four people on game pass ultimate
that's 15 dollars a person
all right
so and i know you're gonna say king well
why would you gain [ __ ] cause i gained
[ __ ] with somebody else and i allow them
to game [ __ ] with somebody else right so
we're supplying it we're suppo supply
and demand right we're supplying the
demand for other people because
financially we can afford that but what
microsoft said was your king we
understand your financial situation and
we're going to help you out
so i got a plus one now because it's
just four of us so i got a plus one now
so i can look over to somebody and say
yo
you need game pass
yeah check this out i can i can look
over to that sony dude that says well
i'm not getting this inside you know my
my my console of choice
there's no day and date i did not see
anything that said day and date for them
not even third party
you know i don't i don't see this i
don't see that effort in in giving back
and this is effort in giving back 100
effort they don't have to do this game
pass is being successful on his own yeah
they do not have to say oh you know what
let's let's let's let's look at the most
successful thing we got that we're
making money off of right now
and let's see let's how how can we
make less money but get more people in
fact
i've never seen this
so they could have easily said
for 20 for five people 50 bucks
yeah they could have easily said that
because think about it two people is is
thirty dollars yeah for the right three
people is 45 yeah so they could easily
said you know what fifty dollars for
five people no they said 25
that's five dollars a guy like y'all
wish y'all can go in the club a real
banging club for five dollars this club
is crazy and then they charge you the
five dollars to get in so i see nothing
but positivity and i don't this club got
the drinks with it
to get drinks i don't know why
people aren't talking more about this
family plan
yeah like this [ __ ] no it's a big deal
it's a big deal i'm sorry in one week
you have the uh you know you got xbox
giving out uh
you know game pass uh at at a a very
reasonable price for a family plan you
got playstation raised the prices of all
the consoles
perfect timing i i always said i felt
like this is a marketing layup and if
they play their cards right and continue
to push these initiatives this is how
you start turning the tide on a
generation this is how you do it you
know so look i i didn't expect this to
come to be honest and into king's
defense like this is not something they
had to do let's just be honest right but
it it is actually really cool it says
that um
you can drive so much engagement because
even if you have those five on and then
you know look little jimmy or whoever
right may get
content or a dlc or skin or whatever
whatever so it still overall helps them
long term for their bottom line and
stuff like that but providing initial
value the only question i got forte is
like how is the
game sharing going to work if you're a
part of that plan that's what i would
because a lot of dudes gave [ __ ] and i
wonder if you got that plan that might
be a wrap unless you part of that
starting five hey hey i think that's you
got to be part of that starting you
gotta be fine that's five and there's a
lot of people like that's the like i
said there's a red hairy
yes so michael listen it's it's
marketing 101. you give you put a price
out there that's amazing and beautiful
and everybody sees it and it's like yo
that's a huge deal but then they forget
about the back end it's like yo but you
know you can only have because you so we
don't know how this is going
but as of right now in order for you to
share a game you have to trust another
individual yes
yo i put my account on yours you put
your euros on mine and we gonna share
games that way but guess what if you're
a family plant owner you have to have
the associated account some kids might
be getting cut off
so somebody gonna get cut off
imagine if they're not in that top five
so so i think this is a two for people
keep saying they're gonna lose money i'm
like
no they might actually gain more money
right because all of those people like
so you gotta think of me and attic are
chefs sharing and then king and uh king
and um cognito is sharing
then you're like well that's that's only
two copies of a game you're really [ __ ]
you're you're really you're um selling
and stuff but you just multiply that
across the entire uh xbox ecosystem or
playstation or wherever that's a lot of
copies of games that's not getting sold
on a continuous basis now they're saying
yo we're gonna give you access to game
pass but now you have to have your own
game library the only gang library
you're going to share is xbox game pass
right that's the that's the library
that's going to be shared and guess what
microsoft doesn't care about that
because guess what all of their first
party games are inside that service
right so what happens is third-party
developers are going to be incentivized
to either put their games in there so
more people can play them or they're
going to run the chance of people saying
yo i'll just wait for a discount or i'll
wait for this because third-party games
microsoft's saying we only get 30 we get
30 of that right whatever whatever you
sell third party we're going to get 30
that means we're going to have the
option to sell more games because more
people are buying them because they're
not inside of our service or anything
like that so you're either going to be
in our service or you're not going to be
in our service and you're going to risk
the opportunity of not selling as much
right so there's a lot of different ways
this can go but i do think that game
sharing yeah i think it's kind of going
out the way yeah i think this i think
it's a soft
sun setting
for people who choose to be a part i
think if you stay out of it well that's
the thought process right the thought
process if you stay out of the potential
family plan then that shouldn't affect
you you'll be fine doing that you know
game share with you with your partner
stop it though that'd be interesting
because
once the family plan come out
i don't think the thing is because of
the whole functionality the whole
functionality of the sharing of consoles
and stuff right if there's anything is
that still a feature of this and that
you got to think about it that kind of
still has to be a function in order for
you to be able to assign people to your
ecosystem or your family so i think
that's still going to be there it just
comes down to
how are they are they how are they going
to incentivize people to say yo which is
better for you to buy your games if
anything
the way that they name this shows that
you know the the sharing of the
libraries are still going to be there
because
it
you know when it comes to this
the game sharing was originally designed
for you to share with your kids
you know that's how it was originally
designed
people took it to the next level you
know let other people use it and i feel
like instead of just naming this to
family plans they they put that friends
at the end for a reason that they didn't
want you to feel like you're breaking
the law because you're doing that's
outside your household
you know i i do
when it comes to the family plan thing
like i think that's generally going to
be directed towards like some group of
friends but i think the core audience is
going to be
households with like three or four kids
one person is sharing multiple game
passes and then one person has to sign
out i think that's going to be the
general direction of this because i
think for the most part people are going
to continue game sharing i i don't think
because a vast majority of the games
that the majority of hardcore gamers
play they're not in game pass day and
day and i don't think that you're if
they made that into it to it's like you
need to do one or the other i think
people would still choose game sharing
because you get access to the legacies
if your friend bought it if you guys
split it you get access to
you know these games that aren't in game
pass but when it comes to the game pass
games you know that's gonna that's gonna
do really well when starfield comes out
red fall comes out you know the the
indie third party stuff sometimes they
get like you know if they put the show
in it again next year it's gonna work
out what for that but i think for the
overall like
as a whole it makes more sense to game
share than it would be to be in there
the interest the funny thing is the more
interesting is how long
is this
like if you put somebody in your friends
list for friends and family for friends
and family how long
are they
dead how are they guaranteed to be in
there
like is it monthly can you like read
because do you you want to think that
there will probably be a timer on that
they're going to say we're not going to
just allow you to move people day by day
minute by minute to that people into
your families and friends oh i
understand what you're saying yeah yeah
so then you would just kick someone off
oh you know i want to play i want to
play this game kick zachary off and push
somebody off so that's the question for
me like what is that because you know
obviously i'm thinking of it like you
know just you know if say braps in my
and my friends and family and then today
he does what he says he's gonna give me
enough and i'm like well i don't want
you all my friends my family
so i boot you off
how long do i have to do that do i do i
have to wait until that month is up do i
have to wait for the to toward the
totality of how long my memory at that
moment is so i think there's a lot of
different layers to that because i think
listen i don't want to
because unless it's family i that was
the only people i would probably just
let rock for a whole year on an account
right no
yeah so that's so that kind of is the
whole the biggest part for me is like
you know i trust like before i'm not
going to have anybody in there that i'm
not going to trust any ways and sure
even if we fall out i know it's just a
falling out because we just disagree on
something you're going to cut down that
flip you're going to cut that game
faster
right exactly you know but for most you
know i actually had a cousin that got
mad at me because we had a disagreement
on uh nintendo and he cut me out of his
nation
[Music]
seriously
because i went to like and i was so
frustrated because i got cut out of it i
was like dude it's it's like 30 like 20
bucks a year i'll pay it like and i
ain't going live man party phone away
about that you know you said i know what
i'm saying here playing this pokemon
online and because i show it because
what it was is i had to call into work
over something serious and he got upset
because he got stuck at work
i get it but at the same time it's like
it's not my fault our management didn't
find you a replacement that's not my
fault and we cousins so why are you
kicking me off your stuff just because
your management didn't do what you did
nice to be nice to you friends family
owners related to it
but look you know yeah i agree i think
it we still have a bunch of little
underlying questions but overall we
think it's a good thing we've got to see
how to implement it the only thing that
we know so far is that you they have to
be in the same country so you can't have
one of your friends
be somewhere else they got to be within
your reach out of this
if king is right and they restructure
the home system to work for game pass
and it doesn't that was the initial
vision that was the initial vision
during the whole xbox one digital area
it
is they're finally gonna come to
fruition no doubt no doubt us i need
some help with the super chest there
let's see so i'm scrolling up jesus
destroyed i gotta refresh
let me see give me one second y'all
gotta pay these videos
gotta pay
listen um if we can get to 700 likes
attic and i is going to do something
incredible for y'all this weekend
i'm going to be giving out codes for
people to
join 700 likes or or eight more members
he's with his members of i'm counting
my job is your job
apollo cooper two dollar super chat you
shouldn't need a group of investors for
one ps5
all right we got that i just want to
make sure i'm not missing nobody we got
yeah we got the rail jack we got the
turtle shadow okay chaos actual um final
super chat family playing about to drop
candy crush magically shows up in my
xbox app game section seems like xbox
about to say to sony if he dies he does
all right
ultimate cold in there salute brother
thank much appreciate that we are at 700
likes no doubt
again 5 super chats
we can support playstation without blind
a ps5 spider-man remastered steve code
he got the clone and shout out to hockey
city he's got a point there man go go
support them on another platform not
playstation wow dead planet two dollar
super chat jim ryan is the best
playstation ceo xbox fans could have
asked for yo bessie i do appreciate them
all shut up
lucious augustus the homie finalist in
the chat family plans are more sticky
compared to individual plans it's harder
to leave the service when four other
people are using your plan it's smart
that's true
people don't want the lights on they got
responsibilities
somebody gonna call you they're gonna
call you hey man hey i can't not play
this game
the hell man it was your month to play
man what's up shout out to hoggy shitty
again finally chad the family construct
already exists go to your microsoft
account profile he's right and you can
manage your family you can add remove
whenever you want yup i noticed that
from the beginning of the xbox one
generator that was always there good
catch by hoggy shinny i think we're all
caught up let me get a little short i
know i see some subscriptions though
hold on hold on jay primo jay primo
member for three months lebron's just
got to say i love you guys keep up the
great work much love jay primo salute we
got her members below
yup pragmatic pragmatic eagle member for
34 months lower goal microsoft allows
one account to make two home console
switches a year but six total changes a
year i imagine it will be the same with
the family plan remember the 360 era
with family plan same rules like yeah
there'll probably be some cool off
period where you got you can't just keep
switching and switching and it's going
to be
why this kid got there probably 30 days
oh no i'm just counting up all the money
that they save no doubt
they're having me save some of the money
you are messy salute salute salute thank
you everybody for that
gamescom make this one fairly quick you
know online live man opening night live
this is addict's topic what did you want
to talk about with gamescom
i mean you know uh jeff keeley had his
event um that's pretty much what i want
to focus this around uh the opening
night live and you know i want to get
you guys over our impression uh me and
dj shout out to dj we actually live
streaming this on the channel so you can
go
on the youtube channel after the podcast
and check out any live reactions that
you guys are interested in uh i want to
bring to the realm and talk to the lords
and you know just exactly what you guys
thought about it if you felt like
there's an improvement from last year uh
you know just your overall
thoughts on it so you know what what
we'll do is we'll start with forte
that's what we're going to start with
[Music]
or
the thing about it is i thought it was
me
to be honest with you um it was a lot of
good stuff there but it was stuff that
we knew about
right and what they did do is they did
do a little bit deeper dives or had a
little bit different trailers and stuff
i love the presence of microsoft there i
love the presence that microsoft is like
you know they stamped itself at these
events and they're showing the people
that are actually taking the time out
because time is valuable to come out to
these events to show their hardware to
show their software to show their their
uh what they're working on um the
biggest takeaway i got from sony
not being there but they decided yo
y'all been asking for this y'all needed
this
everybody wants this
world premiere from sony and dudes
thought it was gonna be
uh get god of war
or something
and they showed a controller
i fell out
i fell out
i mean not saying that that edge
controller is not something that people
want since xbox has the elite controller
you know xbox has the elite controller
and that's a 200 plus uh dollar
controller but
that's something y'all could have did on
your own someplace else you know to
release it put it in a tweet like you
like to do like y'all like to tweet
right so tweet out the controller with
the video or the modulations of it
y'all y'all did this to jeff why y'all
did this to jeff like why jeff had to be
up there to get everybody all lathered
up and bloomed up and ready and thinking
y'all was gonna do something special and
y'all threw throughout the controlling
was like have at it
no man absolutely not that was
absolutely disgusting yeah i didn't have
no presence there and i've i told you
before this level of taking people for
granted is is not good devolver digital
had a lot of good stuff there um
i got a chance to see more pentiment
still not my flavor until i get my hands
on the game
but um i did get a chance to see
people's reaction to it it was more so
the people of gamescom and and the fact
that people were in person and in large
nmas um
having the ability to interact with each
other
like uh games uh conferences of old you
know um so you know we went to pax and
we we noticed that pax was a little bit
opened up a little bit cleaned up
but also at the same time
we we kind of figured that next year's
packs will be kind of back to normal
this what i saw with gamescom was
they learned a lot of things from
probably other conventions
and they implemented all that stuff
there so we saw really good games like
you know liza p which is you know game
pass day and date when it actually
releases shout out to sarah bond and the
team for acquiring such a hot game such
as a
looked after thought after game sought
after game
and you know wasn't that um number one
on the playstation dudes list so if it's
number one on your list just sell your
playstation come over here
over there get rid of that that's a
waste of time right xbox one
but they got the games that you want
right shout out to gamescom for showing
you all the games that you're not
getting day and day in your situation
but it's over yeah um
i'm gonna be messy i'm gonna stay being
messy and i know you guys don't like it
but gamecom
actually eloquates my whole message to
you you're being taken for granted and
you're sitting there frauding like you
do all the time
sony does care about me they don't care
about you if they keep standing you up
every time there's a show oh
interesting thought process right king
makers got some bars as far as showcase
presents and all that good stuff i'll
jump in yeah i thought it was i thought
it was good they had some stuff for me
you know um i thought
high on life i'm gonna shout out mr
maddie plays he's been on the high on
life joint you know saying now when i
first saw
they had like a boss fight what do you
say mr stabby yeah it's that he got yo
the australian night let me cut him let
me get him
like i go front like there's a part also
where see the gamescom footage it was a
little weird because they just went
straight to the boss fight and there
wasn't really no context leading up
there's no context right so i got a
shout out iga shout out to the legend um
ryan mccaffrey who had me on on podcast
a lot their footage pride had to lead up
your king there's this part with a
little alien or whatever and you put a
gun on he's like here you ain't gonna
shoot nothing but you're gonna shoot a
kid you ain't gonna shoot down you ain't
gonna do that and the gun was like yo
don't the gun is your gun is totally
like bro it's a kid like we not gonna do
that like we come on like
and they literally
when you murder the kid
you shot a kid it's just it's gonna it's
gonna have humor that's gonna hit and
it's gonna have people that some people
are gonna like they loose with the mouth
i thought microsoft did themselves a
favor by one attaching themselves to
games like this that they said obviously
don't really usually have also a lot
listen y'all know i'm not the souls guy
liza p bro
and yo that joint look
and then like the puppet joint it makes
the little scariest to it and they
flipping the um you know the story of
pinocchio
crazy um there was a couple other joints
in there for me past is killing it yeah
they doing their thing i thought i even
be honest i'm not even a dead island guy
but i thought dead island told me that i
looked good y'all was real brutal oh
it's two dollars too right now if y'all
know it's inside uh the game store
microsoft store two dollars you know
what actually is leaving game pass that
i was a little disappointed with uh uh
hades hades
it's on sale right now you can go buy
that for fourteen dollars because you
get the ten dollars i mean um the ten
percent sale so right now if it's
leaving game pass you can actually go in
and purchase any game that's leaving
yeah shout out to pictures with g.a that
will shine game look fire um kalisto
protofo call i thought showed well again
yo that looked crazy there was some
joints there was some joints in there
man i i liked some of the joints i've
seen you know it was look it was solid i
just like that we got shows again and
gamescom is back in full swing and um
yeah and shout out to kajima for
debuting his podcast
he's so weird he comes out and he like
does like his own little specific thing
and then he just bounces and it's funny
but yeah shout out to that but um yeah i
thought it was good any other comments
on gamescom on live did anybody like
that forte would be good nah man i was
nope i was asleep
[Laughter]
i was asleep i was asleep i would i i
shouldn't have watched it live yeah
that's probably the biggest problem
right there but i mean there was some
cool stuff there um high on life the
thing about it is it was some stuff that
i saw like i saw a higher life i just
didn't like the presentation of it yeah
but i was already bought in on the game
so once i saw the the extended footage
from ign i was like okay i'm good yes
same day
okay but um
yeah man it was it's just
it just reminds james come just reminds
me of everything that we don't have
coming this year
that's all it did it just reminded me of
all that stuff it also just reminded me
of it
it also reminded me of it being a
business like more than anything else
because once we started seeing as much
as i love pokemon and we see cars on the
stage for pokemon stuff i was like oh we
gotta pay it just you know i never had
the feeling of a show where i felt like
oh it's time to pay the bills right i
never had that feeling before
but now i'm having i had that feeling
during the show and that was just kind
of like the the law through it yeah but
like you said certain like games liza p
and stuff like that everything it was
stuff that was there to show it out like
when it came to dead island i was like
yo this this game is alive yeah it's
still alive you know last time we saw at
first i was a little annoyed because
they were showing the cgi trailer you
know of the
shout out to the fake you know the fake
lenny kravitz
shout out to that but when i was i was
like yo this this this actually looks
cool but did it hit me i said man didn't
the last time we see this game it was a
it was a cgi trailer and that was like
12 years ago it feels jogging yeah with
the jogging and stuff and people falling
out and families falling out yes that
was yeah i was like you know i remember
because it was amazing right but then
but what saved it for me was the fact
that they actually showed gameplay and i
was like yo and and i like the fact that
they it doesn't take itself so seriously
like it seems like a lot of these games
like that want to have this bridge and
like somewhat of reality
dreary post-apocalyptic everything just
just have fun with it and that's what
they were kind of having with it so um
there were some gems in there but it
just reminded me of everything that's
not especially when they did the
most anticipated microsoft award and i'm
like wait a minute what are these games
so that just let me like right there
just let me know like man this is just a
dry year bro this is so dry there's
games coming there's going to be these
people are excited for us
well yeah it's driving us well and also
going to be driving for the playstation
when god will get delayed oh my god
oh well listen listen i i'm trying to
stay away from that one because you know
how you know my feelings on god of war
in 2020 yeah i know you've been uh you
are the king camp i believe yeah
i've been on that way i've been there
since 2021 when they tried to make it
seem like it was coming that year and i
was like no that's marketing sir yeah i
remember that i remember that and it's
not coming this year because it was not
at the gamescom i mean how close do we
need to get for y'all understand this
stuff like that
not showing up buddy you're good though
but the show was okay it just i just
i just envy the people that just decided
to watch youtube clips other than
watching that [ __ ] yeah watching paint
dry live on tv
he's messy no i will come by the last
one this will be quick we get about it
oh look
phil dominus
aurelius spencer outside
rare these days see him outside but um
yeah he's outside he had a interview
with bloomberg talking about what's
going on his thoughts on a lot of stuff
in the industry he's gonna pull up some
stuff from him on that interview is that
some interesting question he said about
the um
talked about his arcade origins which i
thought was it was cool you know as og
kind of talking about what's going on
you know how his his start in the
industry and stuff like that did he
start talking about the activation
policy it feels very strong about it
feels good about it um he talked about
the interesting thing i thought was um
very interesting reference to post
acquisition was more so about that they
remain on the hunt and he said for um
investing in new games partnerships and
further deals xbox they want to add
content and creators in the regions of
the globe where it's less strong he says
i'm always thinking about things that
add to our capability even though we've
worked on our geographic expansion i
like to say that we have too many of our
creators in places that are traditional
markets so yeah i wanted to you know
this is one that's been going around i
want to get your thoughts on what you
guys think about that
and um just in general if anyone that
did catch the interview any bars in
particular and i'll open this up to
anyone who caught it i know it was a
is it kind of kind of an exclusive but
not i don't know if anybody got a chance
to catch it just
i i i tuned in on certain stuff uh when
he was talking about the nfts and he's
like you know there's a place for
natives and dudes took that as oh nfts
is coming to xbox and microsoft supports
nfc thank you is mainly saying there's a
place for everything and nft does have a
shape in the in the industry but i don't
think no one really no one really knows
how to implement
that into it
to make it work i think there's people
that's doing it the wrong way and
there's people that can do it the right
way uh i think i don't think he was
saying yo we're gonna start putting nfts
you want to watch netflix you got to get
an nft first i don't think he was saying
nothing like that i think he was saying
look there's places in the industry for
nfts but we got to figure out where a
good place is
i don't implement them yeah yeah i don't
feel like there's any place in the
industry for nfts but
you know
but back in the day we didn't think
there's a place for microtransactions
and people found good places for them
maybe something like that similar can
happen with nft i don't think it should
be there at all but i do understand
that's an a
an ad revenue and i understand maybe
everyone not just microsoft not just
sony everyone wants to try to do it's
just how you do it well they just want
to try to combat the fact that people
say you don't have ownership on anything
digital that you purchase and
that's the reason that a lot of people
say there is a place for it yeah it just
comes down to
how what does that look like on the
consumer level you know does it look
like something that you purchase inside
of a game like ubisoft was trying to do
or stuff like that yeah with sneakers
that will go through your character just
hasn't been implemented correctly or or
the or the biggest thing is the game
that would feature it the most and the
best hasn't been made yet yeah it has to
be a game that's crafted around the
thought process of the um non-fungible
uh token and people don't even know what
a nft is right to be honest with you you
know so for you to study that stuff uh i
know
me and the lords looked at uh nfts in
certain spaces because when the buzz was
around it that was that but as far as
some of the biggest
talking points that were in this
conversation was really good stuff i
really want you know phil here so we can
actually do a proper interview a
different interview interview that is a
little bit more in depth
a pose of you know
is his youth and stuff like that um
young phil yeah young squabbler um
what what i what i did
take away from this bloomberg joint
sonic homo sonic oh that was that was
yeah that was the masonic that was yeah
they got they got home a call of duty
they got home a halo
sonic so you're trying to fly
someone slipped up for bloomberg or the
promotion of this the last time somebody
slipped that we heard it and i talked
about a dude's thought i was capping it
was something wrong with me can you
reach in your arms you reaching
and i said yo he said we
and why does he have privy uh to to the
knowledge of where game pass is at with
these numbers if anybody remembers that
was back oh straws and um yeah take two
ceo and yeah okay
so when he was talking about the you
know the numbers the bethesda stuff and
all that stuff and then it comes out oh
snap microsoft bob is that yeah you know
the numbers because you ain't bad with
the situation right so the fact that
bloomberg says that emma and and phil
from his own admission phil dominus
maximus really is spencer we will
address him by his name first in his
line
you know
he did say that you know acquisition
season's not over he did say that you
know so if it's not over bro and y'all
just did the biggest joint how do you
follow that up because the joint before
that was a big smash hit
so
how you how do you follow that up
say good y'all dude's been screaming
sega all the time
sonic got a game coming out yeah it's
coming out on november 8th that's the
game that's going to bump god of war
that's how i know
i'm really with this gig that's the fact
this is how i know god was listen that
what was that that that pirate joint
terrible seas what is that terrible
season what is it called what what was
that ubisoft
yeah i forgot the name of it i know it's
about yeah skull and bones
yeah bones said the eighth they're
coming out the eighth right
so so till then
sonic city coming out the eighth ain't
nobody scared a big bad guy to walk like
hey no i've never seen this triple a
most anticipated joint for this
situation we put fifty dollars in both
pull
[Music]
he's just set the hell with your god
awardness
so
how how do sonic have that level of
crazy who needs fear how do sonic get
that when you have a financial backing
of a situation that's going to make some
dude's head spin
so i honestly believe
that sonic got the backing of a trillion
dollar company that he can make these
bold statements because listen if segas
is putting it out right
and i want you to hear me out
sega's putting it out sega is not as big
as god of war as far as uh you know
sonic is i know sonic did great in the
movies and all that other stuff and and
it is a well-known brand but let's let's
talk about these numbers here right so
sonic hasn't been doing those numbers
like god of war 2018 we're not even
going to play that and this is probably
one of the most anticipated titles for
that
so
financially that will be ruined because
you bring in a sonic frontiers uh open
world title
new way that you're doing it to the to
the marketplace
you wanted to have enough breathing
space and nothing that's detrimental
around it as as much as possible
you gonna put it day and date
with one of the most destructive games
that they if if you want to pick i'm
going in the store me you want to store
you are not going to say let me get
sonic
and this is it come on man we're going
to keep it a buck right
and if you did you got an xbox and you
wasn't worrying about the the the
playstation situation
so that's just half the sale but you
want all the sale if you sign it because
it's multiplied right
you won't put it up against such a
juggernaut you won't do that unless you
have the backing of somebody that's
saying do that i got you if you fail
because if if you're saying do that and
somehow some weird way it finds itself
in game pass right right you have these
numbers here and then you can actually
sell over here
yeah there you go lens to a conspiracy
theory that i'm willing to
my own support
i respect that
no i understand when you're going with
it i will say it supports your bet
more with attic
in in the thing because
with the date right because generally we
do
see people stay away like when there's
certain games that's the zeitgeist
people who have been knowing something
some indie developers some some double
that will say hey we're moving our date
you know for reason someone just
outright said cause they're like yo we
not trying to get squashed by something
else that we know is gonna move the
needle on that day we're gonna see we're
gonna see i know you guys feel strong i
can't wait to see how this play out
because obviously the pre-orders did go
up but then like you said you scalables
it's sonic are outside
but it was a good good interview yeah i
just feel
a lot of times because people was upset
with me they just hit me in the dm's you
know the king they not asking him the
good questions they're not asking the
proper questions
they gave him a sheet they gave him a
sheet of 25 questions
and you know they'll check off what they
say what they can do what they can can't
talk about so i'm pretty sure they had a
list of questions that they really
wanted to ask them but he was not
answering these questions right now on
this situation and then
the the audience that they're going for
they're going for a vanilla audience to
get a certain level of
answers
whereas on a podcast such as ours
we have a different demographic that
really mess with phil see these are
introductions to people that probably
don't know the the microsoft ceo of xbox
you know here it is you know oh for real
that type of thing where if he's here
everybody that tunes up to pull up know
who he is they know what it's about so
it's a it's a different type of
interview so here's an introduction to
the world that doesn't know him i can
understand the line of question last
point i would say that he said that um i
want to say caused controversy but
people were trying to get context about
it and this is reference to like
exclusives and he was saying that um you
know in reference to i think that it
started off talking about like cross
play it was asked in full context and
then call of duty came up and he
basically he's saying that he said the
idea of games made exclusively for one
device is something we're just going to
see less and less of maybe your
household your you have to be in a
household to buy an xbox and i buy
playstation and our kids want to play
together and they can't because the
wrong piece of plastic to plug into our
television we really love to be able to
bring more players in reducing friction
making people feel safe secure what
they're playing allow them to find their
friends play with their friends
regardless of what device i think in the
long run that is good for this industry
and maybe in the short run there's some
people in those companies and some
companies that don't love it but i think
as we get over the hump and we see where
the industry can continue to grow it
proves out to be true so i'll just
gently i thought that was interesting
you know because i saw you know some
commentary like well maybe this beads
like he doesn't believe in exclusives
and i didn't necessarily take it that
way i kind of took it as more of the
cross-play initiative in conjunction
with their initiative as far as their
games and wanting their games to be
on other devices you know what i'm
saying because this how i feel and this
i'm just going to speak myself you guys
let me know if you agree
i still feel the activision blizzard
deal is a different beast
because prior to that deal
the talk was zmax and bethesda where
these games gonna go right and at that
point people thought it was gonna be
like a call of duty situation for elder
scrolls fallout star field and the like
and then we found out very promptly
where game pass exists that was the
statement right so i think with the zeta
max joint obviously ftc regulators
this game shout out to jezzy always says
it it is it's a ritual game it's the
biggest game in the games industry and
let's be honest unlike a star field or
an elder scrolls it does thrive and
benefit them to have that on multiple
platforms for the engagement of that
type of game especially when you bring
up nintendo switch where they never had
no call of duty game and you would dig
they're looking at that kind of thing so
what my point is when i hear him say
this stuff i also think
moving forward he's talking about that
next acquisition whether it be regions
i'm totally with you king when he says
regions we're not strong enough to me
that screams japan that screams you know
all these other monk look man sega you
already know how i feel i'm the second
kid i'm completely biased i it's a lot
of sega kids became xbox fans that's a
fact so you know i would love to see
that i would like to see a you know
japanese studio i would love to see you
know a fighting game genre studio
something in that
to really
free up those deficiencies but um i love
that talk because to me you're
recognizing that you still have work to
do
and they're not done right so it's just
going to be whether or not it's on a
smaller level from a developer
standpoint or if they continue to go
with the bigger publishers but i thought
that was interested any final thoughts
on the interview attic anybody else
good
no i'm fine okay cool cool no doubt
you're ready to eat
you got to eat facebook i i just find it
i find it
people don't really hear they try to
hear right it didn't really hear if he
says
uh places that they're not strong in
what's the place that he keeps going to
oh yeah he's been doing well in japan as
far as i'm going to japan improving it
you know um sega and his relationships
you know uh with sega as far as all
these rpgs and the fact that we get
persona now
um
these things is huge atlas just dropped
the game uh yeah yeah i saw it being a
ceremony
on xbox platform shout out to sarah bond
and the team
they again again
doing things that aren't commonplace
over in the microsoft and xbox equals
ecosystem right
for him to say that
for them to have that slip in the
beginning
i i don't know man and and and for them
to have the balls to go on the november
eighth day
um it just it leads to
aggressiveness the the new
aggressiveness that microsoft has been
proven to show it goes back to uh the
family plan and being aggressive there
goes back to day and date and xbox being
aggressive there it goes to being
aggressive
and and pushing in spaces where you need
to grow yeah to to when there's a supply
constraint for them sending the money
instead of sending money to block a game
from the other console you send money to
free up
these uh semiconductors to get more
systems out there
you know you put money in good places to
to be aggressive where you had a
deficiency yeah you don't play defense
you play offense you play offense to win
those people that sit back in in in
a cover 10
at the end of the game and you down you
know you up 14 points you look back and
you lost by one by that field goal you
try to figure out how tom brady did it
to you again
because you went into that cover 10.
[Laughter]
and i'm watching the level of aggression
that microsoft is showing they're
showing a level of aggression inside
marketing they're showing a level of
aggression when it comes to uh game pass
they're showing a level of aggression
when it comes to the console because
this console is the cheapest and also
the most powerful
right so there's a level of aggression
that microsoft is showing and there's a
level of intimidation that they're
putting their foot down and and and
these other dudes is fearful boy no look
it's a new generation we like i said i
like i love
when they try to improve on deficiencies
and they've done they've done a lot
nothing yet but this year and like i
said when i look at what i look at i see
the persona series i'm out here playing
maraca blade point which is a
actually amazing game that historically
would have probably never
would have missed the xbox console right
let alone debut for the times exclusive
or whatever it is you know what i'm
saying and i'm starting to see the
straws the atlas thing and all that
stuff that's what you want to see you
want to see the strike the kojima thing
you know they're continuing to improve
it that's all you could ask for you that
was one of the main issues i had with
the xbox one generation like what is
going on and why don't you own and
control your own ips you know the same
kind of thing and that's what you got to
see but anyway that's what i got um no
poll because being addict got an
announcement as far as next week or oh
yeah so let's talk about that let's go
ahead and do this now
uh next week
uh look
saul might be able to host next week but
we're not going to put that kind of
strain on him in his voice we want to
give him plenty of time to recover
cog will be out of town so there will
not be an iop next week because he's
going to packs but what we're going to
do is me and king and maybe solve if he
has enough time and if he's feeling up
to we're going to have a community night
uh you know we're going to play you know
fall guys fortnight we're going to do
you know games where we could just throw
in the chat you could join you could
play with this he could uh you know
things like that i think uh we have
enough people we could easily play
something like fall guys we're going to
try to keep it to cross play games to
make it as easy as everyone in the chat
as possible to jump in and you know
we'll
have conversations there'll be a fun
time man uh you know but there will not
be no ilp next week no doubt no that's
right but we gonna play games with you
paul
you know i'm shooting for pub g i want
pub g to be on that list to be honest
with you i really do i really do i
really want to catch one of you dude
just pop pop you in the ribs you running
back hey brat remember that we have fun
with pup g baby
put you back i want you back now that is
playing right
i just let it doubt so you got it here
first let's get some out children and
then i'll read the super chats towards
the end again salute to my man mr babish
so to jay fonzarelli go support the
playstation trophy room over support
games talk live they out here doing it
really big and it was cool to get there
yeah sadly
he he he goes late like fawns i was
going to send our people to him but he
still but he goes too late yeah just
like i can't do nothing but uh i found
someone else for you guys
so you know you guys can follow me on
twitter at lord addict
14 he was here
he's been muted like half this podcast
he don't get no outro
wait wait wait wait just
so
[Laughter]
this is what i do i'll wait for y'all to
perfect it so we got to do the other
raid so after y'all finished this one we
go back and i don't know what that vowel
disciple carried for no no no i just
want to play the raid dude but
yes
no
no i've been playing fortnite so don't
you even look at me where can't people
find you four times
wow wow you can find me about to watch
top gun maverick on my xbox you know
where i was one of the very first places
you could watch it no uh but the outside
of that man great show as always really
appreciate the invite to come through
gaming forte everywhere youtube twitter
xbox live playstation the dps podcast
every thursday night 9 p.m with the
homeboy slow-mo backslap shout out to
all the 10 percenters out there that
don't want to pay more money for their
products um but yeah the amazing show
really appreciate it and um we will
catch you guys sunny side no doubt much
love brother my destiny bredrin overall
good dude yo love seeing what you're
doing on the channel and the shifts you
make it there and
seeing the success there and of course
dps man always always loves oh yeah
gotta love the destiny community
they come they come out when you make
good content though thank you they come
outside they come outside i'll be back
soon salute to you lord addict now we're
going to have you provide you what you
got going on find me on twitter lord
addict iop i already see people on
twitter tagging king and stuff saying
thanks uh
you know thanks
thanking him for
saying the importance of japanese games
on the xbox platform you know what
i i
that irritates me you don't need videos
you've been the fastest
thanks for it
i appreciate everyone coming through we
had up to over a thousand people you
know we do hit over a thousand on
special occasions and i uh thank every
one of you coming in here we got
74 people in the chat right now
definitely that like but let's get that
above 800 before we end the show we'll
be back next week playing fall guys
fortnight i guess
he'd be pushing his games
no
i'm picking games that you could just
put a put a code in and join okay
don't put up that cooking mama's
cooking mama you mean to overcook it
people call me selfish and i'm looking
out for the chest
[Laughter]
yes
well first elmer p
thank you brother and you know i do know
the importance of uh japanese games on
the xbox platform so i do appreciate you
my man oh my p he outside give a shout
out to elma for watching for reporting
and tweeting i always respect that and
and you know you follow me i follow you
back uh finally made it to 10k which is
incredible and incredible within itself
relationships awesome
it's absolutely nexus
a little silly old me interacting on
twitter right um
i was gonna do a combat talk with the
king this weekend but next weekend i'm
gonna do a combat talk with the king
it's a long weekend we have um
ortiz
versus uh rues and it's going to be
fantastic but um
guys what up this is a serious thing
the fact that
y'all y'all have to be vocal
you have to be vocal if if if if you
find it and it's not even reversible
guys it doesn't take effect until
september 15th and it gave you the grace
period in order to hear how loud you're
going to scream and how big you're going
to market and and and talk about the
fact that the 50
50 50 hike
and the console price is crazy please do
so i got mine i don't got to fight for
you
i already got mine
i don't have to be vocal i have a
playstation 5.
it's collecting dust
but i have it
right but but i don't respect
this what they're doing to you guys and
um we don't have to live by the credo of
of of you know um taking what they have
to offer we are the consumer you know um
and we don't have to go by yesterday
shout out to joe craig don't have to do
that and it was so much fun today i want
to give a shout out to fonzarelli for
yeah
uh my man bad bit for coming through i
literally was looking at some pictures
of us at uh at uh what was it uh pax
east and my man came outside and he's
out there so shout out to the trophy
room yeah shout out to my brother
forte we have the longest running inside
joke
on uh on this podcast and i do
appreciate him you know every every
sense of the word because we even did
raids together we don't you know play
destiny together i'm trying to get him
over here on fortnight with me i got his
i got i got he got his other half with
me
i'm already on for tonight so you just
haven't played with me yeah that's it
that's it i just got to pull you over i
just i said like i said play with your
calls
but uh cog yo i know i was a handful
today
i know i was a handful and you did a
masterful job and and and wrangling
themselves i was innocent
i lost the battle many times but i had
to let it go
how i feel shout out to the playstation
texas division i feel i told you guys
mike and jim can't come back but
did we ever get a name for this this
person executive insurance
you know i'm not going to give a name to
cause i got a trouble
but i'm gonna tell you this
don't you buck up
[Laughter]
don't you buck up
i just don't like the the fetishes of
this character you know what
that character the domination talk that
character's name is carl
yes and you can you can catch me on that
near that microsoft right there that
xbox that xbox over here
same thing king david otw but if you
want to see me on that playstation brand
that's right where we we've raised the
prices on you
[ __ ] up on me don't you don't you have
to pay an extra fifty dollars to see it
but you can see xbox 360.
one man
catch me over there so i want you dudes
to come out have a good time play with
us pause but i'ma tell you
right now all this character be going
left anyway oh
i'm gonna need some help we got a super
chats bruh we got super chat but um try
to all kill them up yeah so you already
know what i mean appreciate the love man
appreciate the love i don't know the
last one that was okay i'll i'll go back
as far as i can i just want to shout out
the community for um showing love when i
i pulled if we missed any members or
chats that we apologize yeah all right
so where i think
we were
sir x-men i think he said the two hours
of a child i've been saying for nine
months only on welfare um
shinny he says on final super chat how
much is that controller going to cost
i'm sure it it will be
inflation-adjusted especially with all
the blowing you have to do to use it
wow
from donna talk who sony really wants to
be xbox is inevitable that ragnarok is
going to get delayed so they bought out
a new controller to tie this over we got
a five dollar supercharger from heart
geeks to me i thought games called uh
onl was really good over 40 game
announcements everywhere by the guy who
made gta 3 through uh through five dead
island two so many highlights got a two
dollar shot from sir x-man
parents will buy sonic for their
children shout out to mad mandigo
mcdickens member welcome to lord bronzer
i think i'm now caught up with i think
yeah rel ruger two dollar super chat
bloomberg said xbox owned sonic yeah
that's interesting comment that's what
we gotta see later yeah that was
interesting how do you mess up how do
you mess that up
unless they know something we do shout
out to everboy and shout out the kid
y'all on it y'all go hard hey i'd love
that to be true if there was a slip up
we'll see once that happens we already
know who next capcom
okay so then we got a two dollar super
chat from rails
yeah you got that
10 ultra trap from one bad mother king
provided hilary stand up today you have
real talent sir that said we want
intense competition to continue into the
next gaming paragon jim needs to stop
providing king with material got a five
dollar shooter from cosmic dude
go to the lords michaels i said sony if
you ain't ha
here if you ain't here to play on the
biggest jungle jim why you on the
playground there you go that's crazy and
then we got a two dollar super chat from
five dollars per trap from
hold up
okay no ten dollar street trap from
ducky ducky
sorry i missed most of the show was up
late yeah he's probably up late raided
and trying to oh shout out to the raid
team forget shout out to iop shout out
you know it wasn't the number one team
it was tobacco team that's okay though
y'all still finished it yeah i did that
it took y'all 30 hours to do it
i'm still
[Music]
yeah no doubt again everybody salute the
love yeah
again it says some love to solve while
he's recovering appreciate everybody in
the room man a lot of love a lot of show
we already told you what's going to be
for that is playing my joystick don't
super chat when he not yeah it's real
it's real we lose a demographic i'm not
i'm not going to say that's because it's
his wife i'm telling you it's his life
i'm going to say she she's super chat
one time just to say give me the address
so i can send my panties you understand
i'm just saying i'm just saying whoa
anyways everybody that pulled over the
chat got it
i do want to point out that we will be
directing you to the jamaican gamer he's
a streamer that uh
will uh enjoy his uh his uh call that
he's got that well
no commentary there you go thank you
king he's got i got you man me and you
somebody go brothers
you already know everybody enjoy your
sunday catch y'all on the next one we
out long week baby
[Music]
do
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
you